Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt. Ein Projekt der Metaebene in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 66. Runde in unserer Gesprächsserie. Und ja, heute bin ich mal wieder im ESOC gelandet, dem Europäischen Raumfallkontrollzentrum in Darmstadt, wo ich ja schon oft zu Gast war, weil es hier so viele Leute gibt, die so viel Dinge wissen über so viele relevante Themen für diesen Podcast und so ist es also auch heute wieder. Heute werden wir mal ein wenig uns einen technischen Bereich anschauen, der hier bestenfalls am Rande bisher zur Sprache gekommen ist. Und dafür begrüße ich zunächst einmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Igor. Igor, ja, du arbeitest hier am ESOG, in welchem konkreten Abteilungsbereich?
Well, ich bin seit sieben Jahren in ESOG. Ich leite die Abteilung von den Bodenstationen-Subsystemen. Ich komme eigentlich aber aus der Optik und war 14 Jahre in SDEC, also im Raumsegment, ich sage Space-Segment. Und hier sind natürlich beschäftigt mit Bodenstationen, mit dem Boden-Segment.
Bei Amsterdam, in Holland.
Genau, es ist praktisch bei Leiden.
Genau, Nordwijk.
Und davor halt in Lockheed in den Staaten sechs Jahre. Und davor halt in Zürich, man kann es nicht leugnen. Ich habe das richtige Deutsche eh nicht gelernt. Also Sie hören, ich hab in Zürich studiert, eigentlich Astrophysik und Optik ist mein Hintergrund und promoviert natürlich auch Sonnenphysik. Mit dem habe ich jetzt momentan herzlich wenig zu tun. Aber das Schöne ist, dass wir jetzt versuchen, neue Technologien zu pushen, zu fördern. Es ist oft ein holpriger Weg und wir sprechen gerade über optische Leserkommunikation, also Space-Kommunikation. Was sich im terrestrischen schon lange etabliert hat, hat natürlich über Glasfaser, über sogenannte Free Space.
Genau, darum soll es heute gehen. Bevor wir da aber komplett einsteigen, mich würde das nochmal interessieren mit dem eigenen Hintergrund Optik und Astrophysik. Hast du studiert?
Ja, richtig. Wo? In Zürich, ETH.
Was, also Optik, jetzt ganz allgemein sozusagen, überhaupt erst mal so die Lehre von Licht und wie es sich so leitet, aber dann sozusagen gleich gepaart mit Astrophysik, war das sozusagen Absicht? Also ging es gleich um den Blick ins All?
Seit Kindheit ist man, soll ich sagen, immer fasziniert mit Fliegen. Das ist übrigens mein Hobby, das ist meine dritte Liebe. Und Astronautik, so schön sich vorstellt, die Sterne, das Weite, das Fernweh. Natürlich, wenn man das studiert, kommt man auf den Boden der Tatsachen. Entschuldige mich nochmal für mein Deutsch. Und natürlich, die Beobachtungen vor allem sind ja meistens optisch, seit jeher optisch gewesen. Natürlich gibt es dann eben die Radioastronomie. Das möchte ich also jetzt nicht, soll ich sagen, nebensächlich betrachten. Aber natürlich, die ältesten Beobachtungen sind optisch, passiv natürlich. Und so kommt man natürlich auch mit dem Herz optische Instrumente. Bei Lockheed war ich Instrument Scientist, wie man das übersetzt, für ein Instrument, das Lockheed gebaut hatte, nämlich MDI, Michelson Doppler Imager. Das fliegt auf dem Satelliten Soho, von dem vielleicht Sie alle schon gehört haben. Und das ist ein Sonnen-Observatorium mit verschiedenen Instrumenten. Und MDI ist eines davon, dass die Sonnen beben, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema, beobachtet und die Flüss, die Fluss, ich sage Flüss, Patterns, Fluss.
Der Fluss von...
Also, ob der Sonnenoberfläche, von dem man von vonoberflächlich sprechen kann. Die Flussmuster, so würde ich sagen, von und zu so Magnetfelder flecken und dergleich.
Soho ist ja auch noch ein aktives Projekt.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz ehrlich, weil ich natürlich seit fast 27 Jahren eine Irrtum seit...
Ja, ich denke, es war die Division, die bis Dezember 2018 verlängert, also Soho liefert noch...
Na siehst du, danke. Man ist dann, hoffentlich habt ihr schon mal von den französischen Ausdruckern, deformation professionell gehört und ich mitte in der, mitte im eigentlichen Beruf ist, hat man leider, leider zu wenig Zeit den Horizont aufzuweiten von früheren Projekten. Also ich habe leider mit so nichts mehr zu tun. Dafür hoffentlich sechs Projekte, die auf mich warten.
Aber da ging es im Prinzip ja auch schon um die optische Beobachtung.
Natürlich.
Mit der besonderen Herausforderung, dass die Sonnen natürlich jetzt an das Maximum an Lichteinstrahlung liefern.
Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt bei dem Thema bleiben, das ist auch ein vielleicht oft angenommener Irrtum. Natürlich Schlagzeilen machen, Beobachtungen von sehr fernen Objekten, wo kaum Licht kommt. Und dann gibt es natürlich, von der ESO haben sie auch gehört, man baut größere und größere Teleskope einerseits um Licht einzufangen, andererseits aber natürlich auch entsprechend schärfer abzubilden, wegen der Beugung. Das geht allerdings von der Atmosphäre nur mit adaptiver Optik. Sobald aber natürlich man Spektral auflösen möchte, und das sind nicht die, das ist das tägliche Brot eines Sonnenphysikers, man möchte sehr genau die Spektrallinien erforschen, weil die sagen viel über was da abgeht, hat man plötzlich auch wieder zu wenig Licht.
Bei dem Moment, wo man es aufteilt, verteilt sich natürlich dann auch die Lichtmenge entsprechend.
Richtig. Das heißt, man pickt sich halt eine kleine aus. Aber eben, ich meine, SOHO ist ein Reindes, das ist in verschiedenen Wellenlängen, das hat dann seine eigene Schwierigkeit. Das UV zum Beispiel, also man beobachtet verschiedene Phänomene in verschiedenen Wellenlängen, verschiedene Polarisationen. Also wir wissen, das Licht ist ja polarisierbar, das ist polarisiert, das ist eine elektromagnetische Wellenlänge, hat eine Polarisation.
Also die Welle hat sozusagen eine dreidimensionale Ausrichtung.
Man kann dem so sagen, definiert ist das die Schwingungsrichtung des elektrischen Vektors, der Komponente. Das kennen sie von den Polfiltern an der Kamera oder von halt den Sonnenbrillen, die man ausblenden kann. Richtig, weil nach einer Spiegelung ist das Licht meistens dann ein bisschen polarisiert, vor allem im Wasser, je nach dem bestimmten Winkel. Da sind dann die Sonnenbrillen ja so gepriesen worden, die man beim Fliegen tunlichst weglassen sollte. Ja, also das sind natürlich so hochartig.
Warum sollte man die Sonnenbrillen beim Fliegen weglassen?
Weil, wenn sie beim Landen zum Beispiel eine schräge Cockpit-Scheibe vor sich haben und je nach Sonnenwinkeinfall haben sie plötzlich ein Blackout. Also je nachdem, was sie Licht haben oder wo sie anfliegen und mit dem Cockpit wird gerade das weggefiltert, was man tunlich sehen soll.
So schlimm ist das nicht. Ja, also Optik und Astrophysik, das ist natürlich ein schöner Einstieg. Das heißt im Prinzip war Licht schon immer irgendwie das Thema. Wann kam es denn dann konkret in den Bereich der Kommunikation?
In Estec, also meine Kollegen hatte ich auch vor meiner Zeit. Ich war in Estec in der sogenannten Photonics Electro Optics Section. Vor allem die technischen Entwicklungen halt von der Photonics. Das ist natürlich ein Buzzword für Detektoren, Bildwandler, nicht lineare Optik und Laser beschäftigt. Kollegen dann von der Optics Section, die haben natürlich schon seit über mittlerweile 30 Jahren die optische Kommunikation vorangetrieben, vorantreiben wollen. Und wie immer eine neue Technologie ist das ein schöner englischer Ausdruck, ein uphill battle, ein sehr steiniger Weg gegen das etablierte. Man darf nicht vergessen, in der Raumfahrt, und das ist natürlich nicht so unrecht so, müssen die Risiken minimiert werden. Wenn sie einen Satelliten, der natürlich seinen entsprechenden Preis von den Steuerzahlern hat, will man wirklich möglichst wenig Risiken eingehen. Das ist eine successor Schuld. Nichtsdestotrotz hat ESA natürlich vor allem auch ein Mandat, die Technologie voranzuführen, neue Technologie einzuführen. Dazu gibt es ja die Demonstrationsmissionen oder auch natürlich Bodexperimente, zu denen ich noch kommen werde.
Jetzt ist ja Kommunikation essentiell in der Raumfahrt. Das ist ja ganz klar. Man hat da irgendwelche Raumfahrzeuge im Orbit oder in Deep Space Missionen und das ist alles wenig wert, wenn man die gewonnenen Informationen von Instrumenten nicht bekommen kann. Beziehungsweise natürlich auch nur, um die Geräte erstmal an den richtigen Ort zu bringen, sprich die ganze Steuerung durchzuführen, was ja hier das Kernthema beim ESOC zum Beispiel ist. Jetzt wurde er seit Jahr und Tag, wie sollte es auch anders sein, mit normaler RAF-Kommunikation gearbeitet, also über normale Funk-Kommunikation und da auch dann über die Zeit in den verschiedensten Bandbreiten. Das hat ja im Prinzip ganz gut funktioniert, kann man jetzt mal sagen. Ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es nicht gelungen wäre, Dinge zum Mond und weiter weg hinzuschicken. Satelliten kreisen seit zehn Jahren um den Saturn und man ist in der Lage, sowohl die Daten abzugreifen, als auch permanent die Flüge anzupassen. Warum wird darüber nachgedacht und warum wird auch konkret jetzt hier geforscht und demnächst ja auch zum Einsatz gebracht, die optische Kommunikation? Welche Nachteile hat denn die normale Kommunikation, dass man jetzt hier über neue Systeme überhaupt hat nachdenken müssen?
Das ist richtig, dass wir übrigens auch so bleiben. Die essentielle Kommunikation mit dem Satelliten, was ich mit essentiell meine, ist natürlich das Commanding. Das Wort TMTC kommt in den Sinn. Das ist Telemetry und Telecommand. Telemetry sind die Daten vom Satelliten zur Erde. Das ist dann natürlich zum Beispiel sogenanntes Housekeeping, wo man den Zustand des Satelliten monitort. Und Telecommand ist natürlich dann die Befehlsübergabe.
Du könnt ja auch Englisch reden. Ich glaube, das versteht hier jeder. Ich kenn das Problem.
Danke. Ich kann nichts anderes.
Ich kenn das ja schon. Ist ja logisch. Hier ist Englisch die Haussprache. Alle reden eigentlich in diesem Code.
Eigentlich ist die offizielle Sprache in ESA, so schön offiziell gesagt, broken English. Das wird auch so bleiben, und zwar aus dem einfachen Grund, dass das die robusteste Kommunikationstechnik ist und bleibt so simpelweg wegen, zu Deutsch gesagt, Wetter. Also optische Kommunikation zum Boden und vom Boden geht durch die Atmosphäre mit ihren Wettererscheinungen. Und ganz einfach, wo sie noch mit Radiowählen, Radiofrequenzen noch durch die Wolken zum Beispiel kommen, ist natürlich ein Aus für die Lasertechnik. Und das wird auch so bleiben. Du hast verschiedene Bandbreiten erwähnt. Was hat das auf sich? Die Art und Weise, wie man im RF moduliert. Also ein Signal hat nur, ein Radiowelleverbindung hat nur dann Sinn, wenn man darüber Information überträgt. Das ist dann das Signal. Dazu muss aber die sogenannte Trägerwelle moduliert werden. Sie können es vom Autoradio, wenn sie einschalten, früher war es IMFM, das Amplitude Modulation, Frequency Modulation. Man wackelt also an irgendeinem Parameter, sei es von der Amplitude, also Signalstärke, das ist natürlich die alte und anfällige Methode oder Frequency Modulation. Man wackelt etwas an der Frequenz. Und zwar derart, dass da Information übertragen wird. Ganz einfach, zum Beispiel Sprache, wenn sie genau das Audiosignal darauf modulieren. Und natürlich mit dem Laser, mit der Lichtwelle macht man dasselbe. In einer anderen Art und Weise. Zum Teil ja. Beim RF, also bei der Radiowelle moduliert man meistens die Phase oder verschiedene. Es gibt mehr und mehr fortgeschnittene und komplexere Modulationsverfahren, wo man mit demselben, soll ich sagen, bei der selben Welle mehrere Möglichkeiten hat. Man spricht von 64 APSK, also Amplitude, gleichzeitig Amplitude und Phase Modulation. Das alles ist aber kohärent. Das heißt, man moduliert die Phase einer Welle, die hochgesandt wird zum Satelliten, der empfängt die unter bordeigene Transponder, das ist natürlich ein Transmitter, Transponder ist im Prinzip ein Empfänger und ein Sender gleichzeitig, empfängt die Welle, behält die Phasen starre Kopplung und sendet entsprechend auch zurück Signale zur Erde. Aber das geschieht in einer kohärenten Art und Weise. Das heißt, die Phasenverhältnisse von der gesandten Welle und dann der Empfangene schlussendlich sind starr und daraus kann man zum Beispiel das Dopplersignal verwerten. Dazu kann man natürlich auch das sogenannte Ranging, also die Distanz ermitteln und natürlich das tägliche Brot, wie man auch die Satelliten navigiert, wo man weiß, wie weit sie sind. Und das ist dann wichtig, um Korrekturen vorzunehmen, wie Rosetta. Das ist natürlich schon eine wirklich großartige Leistung, dass man auf diese Distanz und auf diese Genauigkeit dann entsprechend in der Manöver fliegen kann.
Also Rosetta, die Kometen-Landemission, Kometen-Forschung und Landemission, die ja hier sehr erfolgreich zu Ende geführt wurde vor kurzer Zeit.
Genau, also gut, trotz allen technischen Versagen, quasi nach der Landung etc. Die Navigation selbst des Satelliten war ein toller Erfolg.
Ja, ich würde sagen, dass die ganze Mission war eher so 300 Prozent angestrebt, 150 Prozent erreicht. Die Techniker sind da nie zufrieden, aber ich glaube, das war auf jeden Fall eine große Leistung. War ja hier auch bei Raumzeit mehrfach schon ein Thema.
Ja gut, tut mir leid, dass ich soweit ausgeholt habe. Was ich damit sagen wollte, ist die Menge der Daten, die sie pro Sekunde übertragen können, ist jetzt etwas übertrieben, vereintracht gesagt, ist ungefähr die Menge der Wellen, die sie in dieser Sekunde quasi haben. Und das geht natürlich mit der Frequenz einher. Und deshalb wurden die Trägerfrequenzen, die Kommunikation von der RF immer zu höheren Frequenzen verschoben. Mittlerweile sind wir bei sogenannt KA-Band angelangt. Also sprechen wir ruhig von bis zu 32 Gigahertz für sogenannte Deep Space Missionen. Deep Space ist, werfe ich jetzt schon ein, ein Ausdruck für Satelliten, die weiter als zwei Millionen Kilometer fliegen. Also alles, was schon über Lagrange-Punkte sind, durch jenseits von Mond, schon lange. Und natürlich bis zum äusseren Planeten System wie zum Beispiel Voyager heute. Das ist alles Deep Space.
Und Lagrange-Punkte sind halt die Missionen, die halt mehr oder weniger angekettet an die Erde, aber trotzdem in großer Distanz vor, hinter dem der Erde an diesen Punkten schweben, wo sich die Gravitation von Sonne und Erde so wunderbar gegenseitig aufhebt und man von daher mit einem relativ leichten kleinen Orbit immer eine konstante Distanz halten kann.
Genau, wie du gesagt hast. Im Prinzip heißen die Liberationspunkte genau die Gleichgewichtspunkte zwischen Sonne und Erde. Es gibt dann auch zwischen Sonne und Mond und deren gibt es quasi fünf zwischen Sonne und Erde. L1 dort ist zu hoch, das ist dann ein Prozent der Distanz zwischen hier und der Sonne. Lagrange 5 ist zum Beispiel dann so gleich weit weg und man spricht von astronomischen Einheiten. Eine astronomische Einheit, das hören Sie dann mal vielleicht oft, wenn Sie sich mit Astronomie beschäftigen, das ist die mittlere Distanz Sonne Erde, 150 Millionen Kilometer. Also das ist eine AU. Ja und der klassische Frequenz, die zu Anfang, sogenannte S-Band, das ist so ungefähr ein anderthalb Gigahertz-Bereich, wird heute für wissenschaftliche Satelliten halt selten schon verwendet. Natürlich noch diejenigen, die von dieser Zeit noch leben, ist aber sehr lebendig bei zum Beispiel die Kommunikation zu einem gerade gestarteten Rakete. Man nennt das Leop, Launch and Early Operations, weil das wirklich vom Wetter vollkommen unabhängig ist, also das lässt sich kaum stören. Ist allerdings eine niedrige Frequenz, man kann sich nichts stören von anderen Radioquellen. X-Band ist heute der Klassiker und das ist so Richtung 8 Gigahertz, ohne große Details zu gehen. Und wie gesagt, es gibt dann die, heute werden sie etabliert, man ist jetzt wirklich an den Anfängen, um sie operationell einzusetzen. NASA hat das schon, wir sind dran, wir haben es auch schon in der ersten Station, das sind dann 32 Gigahertz. Das heißt, sie sehen, das sind Faktoren dazwischen, das heißt, man kann entsprechend mehr Faktoren. Datenrate.
Genau, das ist ja im Prinzip immer das Thema. Man will ja einerseits eine stabile Kommunikation haben, auch eine fehlerfreie, eine gut korrigierbare Datenverbindung erreichen und man möchte aber natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch eine hohe Bandbreite erzielen, weil man ja in zunehmendem Maße mehr als nur, wo bist du gerade und wie geht es dir, erfragen will. Man möchte gerne am besten noch Live-Video bekommen, etc. Oder überhaupt auch Daten akquirieren von Sensoren, die einfach extrem gesprächig sind, die einfach so viel messen und die auch mit so einer hohen Auflösung pro Sekunde messen, das also einfach mehr Datenübertragung erfordert und wenn man das dann halt mehr oder weniger nicht in Echtzeit erhält, dann muss es ja zwischengespeichert werden und auch das muss ja dann irgendwann gesendet werden, also da beißt sich sozusagen die Katze im Schwanz und deswegen gibt es diesen Run auf auf höhere Frequenzen, weil man einfach in die höheren Frequenzen durch die entsprechenden Modulationen mehr Daten packen kann.
So ist es. Also Wissenschaft einerseits, wie du gesagt hast, nützt niemandem, wenn ein Ziegel da oben herum pflegt und du kriegst keine Daten davon runter. Das hat niemandem was genützt. Das andere, das Video angesprochen, und das nenne ich jetzt wieder ein Thema. Habt ihr sicher überall gelesen. Eine Station auf dem Mond wieder, Astronauten auf Mars, dergleichen. Genau wie bei der ISS, die natürlich mit den Familien auch Video austauscht. Also da gibt es alle möglichen, also Szenarien, wo natürlich wirklich noch höhere Daten raten. Und neuerdings dann natürlich, wenn man von einem Astronaut auf dem Mond spricht, in beiden Richtungen. Heute ist es ja, das spielte ich bei den meisten klassischen Satelliten, ist dieser Link, wenn man so sagt, diese Verbindung an Station Satellite, sehr asymmetrisch. Es braucht wenig Datenrate, um den Satelliten Commandos zu schicken. Man programmiert ja sehr selten was an Bord, das soll auch nicht so sein. Aber viel mehr Datenrate braucht es um den Downlink sogenannt. Also man spricht vom Uplink und Downlink. Und das muss sich ändern, wenn man wirklich eine Mondbesiedlung unterstützen möchte. Und das eine ist die Motivation, um höhere Bandbreite noch zu suchen. Die andere übrigens, die oft vergessen wird, Radiofrequenzen können gestört werden durch dieselben Radiofrequenzen, Interferenzen. Sie haben sicher auch Störsender gehört manchmal im Radio. Wenn da irgendwann der Motor selber stört, dann kommt das Krachen rein. Und um Frequenzzuteilungen wird heiß umkämpft. Das wird sehr heiß gekämpft. In der sogenannten Organisation ITU, International Total Communications Union, da sind sie jetzt in Genf, wird das dann ausgehandelt, welche Anwendungen, welche Frequenzen benützen darf. Ich bin natürlich als Modellflieger damit auch betroffen. Dann hat man die 35 MHz in Deutschland, noch ist das geschützt. Man möchte ja nicht mit einem Modellflugzeug abstürzen, weil jemand reinfunkt. Gut, also die Frequenz Verfügbarkeit wird immer enger und enger. Und natürlich mit der optischen Kommunikation kann man eigentlich einander nicht stören, außer man ist direkt im Strahl und leuchtet genau in den Dioden. Und deshalb ist das. Das zweite große Motivation, um auf Optik nicht auszuweichen, aber dort auszuweichen, wo es eben geht. Großes Thema heutzutage ist genau dieses bei kommerziellen Kommunikationssatelliten. Es schwirren einige im geostationellen Umweg, sie kennen Astra, Hotbird etc. Es geht heute schon relativ eng dort zu. Die Datenreite, Pay-per-view, ihre Teenage-Döchter, die über Satelliten, Internet und so Spielchen spielen wollen, die Bandbreite soll wachsen. Dazu genügt aber so langsam das RF-Spektrum nicht. Und um das RF-Spektrum zu entlasten, das nötig ist, um von den Geostationersatelliten auf ihre Satellitenschüssel weiterhin hohe Datenraten runterzusenden, will man das, was hochkommt, freimachen. Das ist das andere große Thema, sogenannte Trunkline. Und das will man versuchen, das jetzt nun optisch zu tun, sehr hohe Datenraten zu geostationierenden Satelliten, halt optisch. Und zwar im Gegensatz zu wissenschaftlichen Satelliten, wenn es nun eine kommerzielle SATCOM-Applikation ist, dann muss es 99,99% funktionieren. Da kann man sich keine Unterbrechungen der Wolken und so erlauben. Also ist das ein Thema, das daran hochgeforscht wird.
Man redet immer gerne so, da haben wir RF, da haben wir Licht. Im Prinzip reden wir hier über dasselbe Medium, das elektromagnetische Spektrum. Und in den niedrigen Frequenzen, da haben wir halt so das, was wir alle kennen, nicht wahr, Mittelwelle, Langwege, Ultrakurzwälle etc. geht dann eben hoch in diesen Mikrowellenbereich. Und dann geht ja im Prinzip die Frequenz, über die wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben, geht ja so langsam in diesen Terraherzbereich rein. Man würde sich ja jetzt fragen, ok, warum nutzt man den jetzt nicht? Warum ist dann erst der Bereich, den man als Licht kennt, interessant? Also dann kommt ja Infrarotstrahlung, dann kommt jetzt sichtbare Licht. Was ist mit dem Spektrum dazwischen? Ist das nicht genauso nutzbar oder fehlt da, ändert sich sozusagen in der Nutzbarkeit dieses Spektrums an dieser Stelle irgendwas Grundsätzliches?
Ich glaube, das ist Technologie, also rein theoretisch hast du völlig recht. Um ein Link aufzubauen, muss es müssen, aber Licht, also Sendequellen da sein und dann entsprechende Empfänger. Beim alten klassischen Funk ist quasi ein Draht, eine Antenne, einerseits zum Sender, einerseits zum Empfänger. Bei den Satelliten, wo man den Strahl bündeln möchte, das ist übrigens ein anderes Thema, was auch wichtig sein wird, wenn ich zur optischen Kommunikation komme, das Signal soll ja möglichst stark sein an der Quelle. Es breitet sich aus der Art, rein Physik, dass die Signalintensität, also Watt pro Quadratzentimeter, an bestimmten Ort, das verhält sich im Quadrat der Distanz. Also doppelte Distanz, nur ein Viertel der Signalintensität und so weiter. Gut, je stärker ich jetzt nun dieses Signal, sei es eine elektromagnetische Welle, genau wie du gesagt hast, nur die Frequenz ist anders. Je höher die Frequenz, kürzer die Wellenlänge, rein durch die Beugung, mit einer selben Schüssel. Die Schüssel ist ja derart geformt, dass möglichst alles in eine Richtung geht. Wie gesagt, Beugungsbegrenzung, das ist für die Techniker unter euch ein Furie-Verhältnis. Je höher die Frequenz mit einer selben Größe von Schüssel, desto stärker ist der Strahl gebündelt. Bis wo wir zur Optik kommen etc. Dazu braucht es aber entsprechende Quellen. Wenn man im Gigahertz-Bereich geht, dann sind das dann die ganz anderen Quellen. Es sind zwar immer noch Transistoren, aber es sind Traveling-Wave-Tubes, es sind andere Technologien.
Andere Technologien?
Also andere Devices.
Ja. Also versteht das richtig. Man weiß, wie man UKW sendet, man weiß auch, wie man Mikrowelle erzeugt, aber man hätte jetzt nicht die entsprechende Technologie, um das mit Terahertz-Strahlung zum Beispiel zu machen.
Gibt es aber nicht. Es gibt wahrscheinlich Quellen bei allem, aber es muss praktikabel sein. Also die Quelle muss vernünftig Leistung liefern, bei möglichst wenig Leistung Aufnahme und es muss natürlich entsprechende auch Empfänger geben. Es gibt natürlich das ganze Spektrum, kann man abdecken mit gewissen, vielleicht im Labor, aber was im Labor zur Forschung dient, ist noch lange nicht praktikabel für den Alltag, wo man das wirklich auch einsetzt.
Okay, aber wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht, das wäre jetzt, ich bleibe jetzt mal bei dem Beispiel, Terraherzstrahlung, weil das halt noch so unterhalb von dem ganzen Lichtbereich ist, aber eben deutlich über dem, was man normalerweise für Kommunikation verwendet. Also angenommen, ich hätte jetzt einen Sender und auch einen Empfänger, ich hätte das Sender-Empfänger-Problem irgendwie gelöst. Man kommt damit wenig Energie aus, etc. Hat denn dieser Frequenzbereich, also an welcher Stelle ändert sich denn das Verhalten in der Atmosphäre? Wir haben ja vorher gesagt, die Frequenzen gehen problemlos durch die Wolken, das Licht nicht. Ist aber ja eigentlich dasselbe elektromagnetisches Spektrum. Wo fängt es denn an, schwierig zu werden? Also was sondert denn sozusagen die Atmosphäre raus?
Es beginnt schon schwierig. Es sind verschiedene Phänomene. Wolken absorbieren, das sind Wassertröpfchen, die absorbieren, ich glaube, sehr, sehr lange Infrarotwellen, also wie du sagst, sogenannte quasi Optik-Sub-Millimeter. Das sind dann hundert My-Wellenlängen. Allerdings die Phase, also die verschiedenen Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeiten. Wie soll ich das sagen? Alle kennen das Flickern der Sterne, wenn sie außen drauf gehen. Sie sehen über einem Schornstein ein Schmiermuster. Was bedeutet das? Eine schöne Ebene Welle, die sich ausbreitet. Wenn sie auf Turbulenzen stößt, wird sie verzerrt. Entsprechend, wenn man das abbildet, ist die Abbildung eben verzerrt und flickert natürlich mit der Frequenz, wo die Turbulenz halt hat. Und die Atmosphäre kann bis zu einem Kilohertz quasi die Turbulenzen haben, meistens um ein paar Hundert Hertz. Und das sehen sie, wenn sie Sterne angucken. Flicker, Flicker, twinkle, twinkle little star, das funkelnde Sterne. Und das Phänomen tritt natürlich auf, das merkt man. Und zwar, wenn sie, die Astronome, wenn sie einen Stern genau scharf abbilden wollen, geht das halt durch die Atmosphäre nicht. Das ist zwar keine Wolke da. Es sind ein anderes Phänomen. Es ist die Wellenqualität, die leidet, die Abbildungsqualität. Deshalb wenden schon lange Astronomen, vor allem bei großen Teleskopen, sogenannte adaptive Optik, die man in Echtzeit, also man spricht wirklich dann von Hunderten von Hertzwandbreite, die Welle korrigiert, damit es ein möglichst scharfes Bild gibt. Diese Phasenverzerrung tritt schon bei 30 Kilohertz auf. Das ist ein fließender Übergang. Und ich glaube nicht, ich muss sagen, mir fehlt natürlich hier die Expertise, bei welchen Submillimeterwellen was genau wo einsetzt. Aber die Problematik kennt man sehr wohl jetzt schon im RF-Bereich, im 30 Gigahertz-Bereich. Wo sieht man das? Wenn sie zum Beispiel mehrere Teleskope, wie die Radiostromen tun, zu einem Array, zu einer, ja wie soll ich sagen, einem Array, ich kann es nicht besser sagen, synthetisieren.
Also Array ist ja sozusagen, dass man quasi ein großes System in viele kleine Systeme aufbricht.
Richtig. Und wenn man es kohärent macht, ist es ein Phased Array, das ist das, was die Radiostromen machen, um die bessere Auflösung zu kriegen.
Das ist ja generell der Trend bei den Bodenteleskopen, dass man halt nicht mehr so große Systeme baut, sondern man baut halt viele kleine, die parallel empfangen, wo das dann eben durch Software zusammengefasst wird.
Richtig. Und Software zusammengefasst, wie gesagt, die Phase muss dann wirklich an einander gekoppelt sein. Und zwar die Phase in einem Wellenlängen-Bereich, wenn man vom Licht spricht, also das VLA in Chile, von der ESO, also Europäischen Southern Observatory. Die Lichtwellenlänge ist ja ein halbes Mü, dergleichen, also ein halbes millionstel Meter, also ein halbes tausendstel Millimeter. Auf diese Genauigkeit müssen quasi Signale respektive die Teleskope auch gestimmt sein. Das ist nicht trivial. Also es beginnt quasi schon bei Radiowellen, wenn man das machen wollte.
Gut, das heißt also im Prinzip diese Verschlechterung des Signals, dem Moment, wo man durch die Atmosphäre der Erde durchzieht, betrifft eigentlich alle Frequenzbereiche, nur eben unterschiedlich stark. Das heißt schon im T-Reiherz-Bereich, der theoretisch nutzbar wäre, wo man aber nicht in demselben Maße die Technologie bereits entwickelt hat, wie man das in den unteren und auch in den Lichtbereichen schon getan hat, würde darunter leiden. Licht ist ja sozusagen vor allem deshalb interessant, weil man so gut damit umgehen kann, weil es sozusagen so eine entwickelte Technologie ist.
Richtig, das ist so. Der sichtbare Licht voran, wie gesagt, die Detektoren gut am Anfang war es ja Film. Silizium-Detektoren sind natürlich hoch etabliert, alles schon sehr ausgereift und das ist das, was sie heutzutage in den kleinen Handys schon haben. Silizium, APS, Active Pixel Sensors, CMOS, das ist die Technologie, wo man Silizium verarbeitet zum Beispiel.
Würde unser Auge quasi im Terraherzbereich sehen, was es nicht tut, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich die Technologie in dem Bereich besser.
Wenn uns Gott die richtigen Materialien dazu gegeben hat, was mich vielleicht ansprechen sollte, wenn wir jetzt wirklich bei der Optik sind, die Atmosphäre, Gott sei Dank, schützt uns vor gewissen Strahlen, sprich auch UV. Die ist ja nicht überall gleich transparent, wenn man also in diese Frequenzbereiche geht. Obwohl es richtig ist, von Frequenz zu sprechen, sobald man mit Licht zu tun hat, spricht man dann gerne von Wellenlängen. Das ist natürlich komplementär. Bei der optischen Kommunikation, aber auch Sensorik, also Kommunikation ist das eine, aber natürlich schon lang verbreitet sind Sicherheitskameras, die in Infraroten arbeiten, natürlich auch im militärischen Bereich, Sicherheitsbereich, oder auch Hobby- und Nachtsichtgeräte. Die müssen in sogenannten Atmospheric Windows, also in die Atmosphären Fenstern, weil die Atmosphäre ist durchsichtig in gewissen Fenstern und absorbiert woanders, Gott sei Dank zum Beispiel auch im UV. Und diese Fenster, die haben die Technologieentwicklung auch entsprechend geprägt, also das gibt es klassischerweise die 900, also sprechen vom Infraroten, gut das sichtbare Spektrum ist das, was wir von der Sonne sehen, also von großem Modus 0,4 bis fast 1 µ, also 900 Nm um da herum sind Laser entwickelt worden. Das sogenannte zweite Atmosfischfenster für optische Kommunikation war 1,3 µ und was sich zusätzlich etabliert hat ist natürlich auch 1,5 µ. Jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich eine Verwirrung gestiftet. Diese Fenster, von denen ich jetzt gesprochen habe, 0,9, 1,3, 1,5 µ, die gelten vor allem für optische Faser, für Glasfaser. Die Atmosphäre ist durchsichtig in allen diesen Bereichen, natürlich bis zu, da kommt das thermische Infrarot und dergleichen. Entschuldigung, ich bin jetzt gesprungen eigentlich zur terrestrischen Kommunikation. Schon lange bei den Telefonen, beim Internet etc. sucht man natürlich schon lange auf immer höhere, höhere Bandbreiten. Das heißt, man hat schon lange auf Licht ausgewichen, und zwar durch Glasfaser. Und deren Sichtfenster sind diese drei. Warum erwähne ich das? Weil natürlich die Technologie in diesen Bereichen sehr hoch durch den Markt getrieben wurde. Und da versucht man natürlich im Weltall für Kommunikation auch sonst davon quasi zu profitieren. Der Markt selber beim Weltall ist kein großer. Es wird nie ein Markt sein. Man kann nicht kaum vom Markt sprechen.
Ist klar, weil will ja nicht jeder einen eigenen Satelliten haben, geschweige denn optisch damit kommunizieren. Von daher muss man sich quasi auf die Technologie konzentrieren, die ohnehin hier auf der Erde im Einsatz ist.
Ja, ein. Also marktform. Genau.
Aber man profitiert natürlich stark davon.
Absolut. Absolut. Es ist, dass kann ich auch zu einer Falle werden. Also eines ist klar, was ich mit Markt meine, es werden nicht Millionen von Devices verkauft werden. Man profitiert davon einerseits, das ist richtig, unter dem Boden kann man 100% davon profitieren. Sobald allerdings etwas fliegt, muss man es qualifizieren, was bedeutet das? Man muss zeigen, beweisen, dass es den Weltraum aushält. Wesentlich in drei Dinge. Das einfachste ist Vakuum, sonst muss man es einpacken, da wird es teuer und schwer. Das zweite ist die Strahlung und die ist nicht ohne, besonders für Silizium, Elektronik und solche Dinge. Also da gibt es Protonen von der Sonne, es gibt Elektronen, Gamma-Strahlen sind ja nichts anderes als elektromagnetische Strahlen, dann aber wirklich Röntgen und dergleichen, das sind ja genau dieselben elektromagnetischen Wellen, aber hoch energetisch. Und natürlich das, was kommerziell für den Boden entwickelt wurde, für terrestrische Telekom, das ist natürlich nicht für den Weltraum entwickelt worden. Und die Anforderungen für den Weltraum sind schon einiges höher. Wenn man Glück hat, überlebt eine Laserdiode, ein Device.
Du kannst auch auf Englisch sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das heißt.
Ein Gerät.
Eine Komponente. So, danke, das warte ich. Eine Komponente, diese Umgebung für eine bestimmte Zeit. Das ist nicht das andere. Die einen überleben für zwei, drei Jahre. Das ist vielleicht ein wissenschaftlicher Untertitel. Okay, wenn sie allerdings Telekom, kommerzielle Telekom-Anwendungen haben, dann spricht man mindestens von 15 Jahren. Das muss dann funktionieren. Und das meinte ich mit Jain. Damit hatte ich in Estek zu tun, wo wir dachten, okay, Leser 155, Instrumente für 155, easy, alle Komponenten, die sind da. Das ist wohl so. Aber die haben ihre Schwierigkeiten mit der Strahlung.
Das heißt, steckt man mal in die Strahlungstestkammer im Estek und dann bleibt da nichts mehr übrig?
Funktioniert auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so. Richtig.
Es bedampft nicht. Aber von der Kommunikation bleibt halt nichts mehr übrig.
Richtig. So ist das.
Gut, ich fasse mal so ein bisschen zusammen. Wir sehen, RF-Kommunikation war überall und wird auch überall bleiben. Hat sich einfach für wichtige Sachen, für Staats, etc. bewährt. Und es ist halt auch klar, man hat hier das richtige Verhältnis von Zuverlässigkeit, Datenkommunikation und Atmosphärenresistenz bei SAM. Aber für hohe Bandbreiten muss man sich in irgendeiner Form steigern. Das Optische bietet sich jetzt an. Einerseits, weil es eben in der Technologie, die wir jetzt hier am Boden haben, in der Computertechnik, in der normalen Netzwerkkommunikation haben, einfach vielfältig erforscht gebaut und entwickelt wird. Man muss nur schauen, dass man eben die Technologie nimmt und die Komponenten nimmt oder die Arten und Weisen nimmt, die dann eben auch den besonderen Anforderungen im All, wie zum Beispiel der Strahlung und anderen Einschränkungen, eben genügen. Darauf hat man sich jetzt im Prinzip konzentriert seit Anfang der 90er Jahre. Ging das erst so richtig los?
Viel früher. Viel früher, schon 70er-Jahren, mit CO2-Lesern. Wie gesagt, alles hat, im Labor hat man schon viel früher damit, wie soll ich sagen, experimentiert, erfolgreich etc. Wie man es definiert, ich glaube, Anfang 90er-Jahren tatsächlich, kann man sagen, mit dem Silex-Terminal auf Spot 4 und auf Artemis. Das waren Missionen. Das war das erste europäische Experiment im All. Damals noch mit einer Laserdiode, also nicht einem Solid-State-Laser, also einem Festkörper-Laser, sondern mit entsprechenden schwachen Leistungen. Und damals noch mit 56 Megabit pro Sekunde. Und zwar von Spot 4, das war ein Erdbeobachtungssatellit, das in näherer Erdumulaufbahn. Ich schicke es mal voraus. Die verschiedenen Orbits, bezeichnet man als Leo, Geo, Meo, etc. Heo, das heisst nichts anderes als Low Earth Orbit, Geostationary Orbit, Medium Earth Orbit, Highly Elliptical Orbit. Und dann eben halt Lagrange, respektive Libration-Punkte, dann halt Deep Space. Und also Leo-Satelliten, das war das Experiment in Silex, unter der Federführung von DLR. Da hat die Firma an damals Bosch Telekom, TESAT, das sogenannte LCT, Laser Communication Terminal entwickelt. Und da gab es Experimente mit TerraSAR und auch ENFIRE mit der NASA, mit der Air Force, nicht nur NASA. Erfolgreiche Experimente vor allem zwischen Satelliten. Also das TESAT LCT ist vor allem entwickelt worden zwischen Satelliten, also Inter-Satellite-Links, wo die Atmosphäre nicht stört. Und dort wurde eine Technologie eingesetzt, auch die Koherente, nämlich sehr ähnlich wie bei RF. Es ist nämlich interferometrisch, wo man also die Phase des ankommenden Signals koppelt mit der Phase des sendenden Lasers. Und es ist ein bidirektionaler Link. Das heißt, es ist ein symmetrischer Link, also in beiden Richtungen.
Also dadurch, dass man quasi zwei Phasen nutzt und nur die Differenz davon misst, hat man ein stabileres Signal?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen stabiler. Es ist einfach ein hoher Datenrat, also ein BPSK, sondern Binary Phase Shift King, also man wackelt die Phase zwischen zwei Werten, also plus minus 180 Grad und damit ergibt sich quasi Bit 0 oder 1. Und der Vorteil davon ist, dass man alle Signale, welche nicht phasengekoppelt sind, quasi zu denen blind ist. Das Interferometer sieht die nicht. Das heißt, da ist automatisch ein sehr schmalbaldigen optischer Filter eingebaut. Und das ist wieder ein anderes Thema. Man kann damit praktisch durch die Sonne kommunizieren. Was natürlich stört, wie gesagt, wie beim RF, stört einfach ein Hintergrundslicht. Also wenn man natürlich ein sehr helles Licht im selben wellenlängen Bereich hat, wo man kommuniziert, dann stört das. Das gehört dann zum Rauschen. Wenn sie allerdings kohärent kommunizieren, haben sie es genau mit dieser Interferometrie quasi herausgefiltert. Und das ist der Vorteil dieser Technologie. Da es kohärent ist, ist die Wellenqualität, ist die Strahlqualität von absoluter Bedeutung, und deshalb funktioniert es perfekt ohne Atmosphäre. Durch die Atmosphäre hat man auch demonstriert, das geht auch, braucht allerdings am Boden eine adaptive Optik. Und das macht es ein bisschen teurer. Man kann damit durch die Sonne kommunizieren? Durch die Sonne meine ich damit, dass sie quasi, wenn das Satellit vor der Sonne hindurchfliegt, da kann man weder Radio, also die Sonnenstrahlung ist derart stark, dass sie weder eine Radiokommunikation aufrecht erhalten können und natürlich optisch auch schon gar nicht. Mit dieser Technologie kann man also praktisch durch die Sonne tracken. Also das Satellit vor der Sonne durchfliegt, dann...
Vor der Sonne, aber nicht hinter der Sonne.
Nein, genau richtig.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch ein bisschen überrascht.
Ja, sorry für den Jargon.
Okay, dann mal zurück zu der Historie. Also es gab erste Experimente in den 70er Jahren, die im Prinzip schon mal gezeigt haben, das geht im Prinzip.
Am Boden, ja. Kommunikations-Laboraufstellungen. Gut, ESA ist nicht die einzige. Die NASA natürlich hat Experimenten durchgeführt, ob man überhaupt vernünftig tracken kann. Also Pointing. Wie heißt das? Die Strahlausrichtung beibehält. Die Japaner mit NICT haben im Moment Fliegen, die natürlich auch, das ist nicht das dritte, doch die zweite Generation optischen Terminals in diesen Low Earth Orbit SOTA, Small Optical Terminal. Das sind alles Experimente. Und ich habe T-Satz LCT erwähnt. Und durch diese Danik-Federführung war DLR, also mit Kooperation von ESA, durch DLR entwickelt das Terminal selber. Das ist das einzige heute, oder das erste kann man natürlich sagen, das einzige kommerziell und operativ eingesetzte Terminal auf EDRS, auf den Alpha Satz und den Sentinels.
Wenn wir von Terminal sprechen, wir reden jetzt von einem Gerät, was optische Kommunikation mit Laser betreibt.
Richtig, das ist ganz, ganz richtig.
Also LCT ist so ein bisschen der Begriff, der sich jetzt hier rausgebildet hat, der allgemein dafür verwendet wird.
Allgemein richtig und das hat sich dann, wie das Wort Kleenex, hat sich ein bisschen jetzt auch für das Thesat LCT entwickelt, wobei natürlich es ist ein Laser Communication Terminal, es ist ein absoluter Überbegriff. Und der Terminal genau ist diese Box, wo Licht rein und hinter Signal raus, kann man sagen, oder? Umgekehrt, elektrisches Signal rein, vorne Licht raus. Ja, blöd gesagt. Und das ist das, was auf diesen Satelliten fliegt, operativ, also wirklich eingesetzt in einen operationellen Szenario. Was heißt das? Nicht mehr als Experiment, sondern im Alltag Providing Service. Also die Sentinels sind Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, die je nach Instrument, es gibt optische Instrumente, es gibt ein Imaging Radar, also Synthetic Aperture Radar. Und damit man die Daten von fast in Echtzeit über einem anderen Kontinent im Moment, wo der Satellit in niedriger Erdumlaufbahn umkreist und zum Beispiel Bilder liefert von einem Tsunami oder sonst Geschehnissen auf der Welt in Asien. Und anstatt dass man wartet, bis der Satellit 20 Minuten, halbe Stunde später über eine Bodenstation ist, wo er die Daten herunter senden kann, kann er von dort optisch die Daten zu einem sogenannten Relay-Satellit an der Zwischenstation. Genau, das ist ADRS, European Data Relay Satellite, das ist der Name, im geostationären Orbit, also auf 36.000 Kilometern Höhe. Verbleibt ist der falsche Wort, aber dreht sich mit der Rede um. Und der geostationäre Satellit sendet dann normal per RF an die Station weiter. Und so hat man fast in Echtzeit die Bilder. Und das wird also operativ eingesetzt. Cool, das ist ein anderes Anwendungsgebiet, als wir jetzt in ESAWG von der Bodenstation-Seite nämlich ansehen. Und das ist dann sogenannte Deep Space Optical Communication.
Wollte mal kurz zu den Begriffen noch was sagen, zum Verständnis, wenn wir von den Sentinels reden, reden wir von den einzelnen Satelliten des Copernicus-Programms, das neue Erdbeobachtungsprogramm der ESA. Ursprünglich mal unter dem Titel GMES gestartet, dann Copernicus genannt. Und ja, da haben wir jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Satelliten, die dort bereits gestartet sind und noch sehr viel mehr, die noch gestartet werden. Wird im Übrigen hier auch bei Raumzeit demnächst ein weiteres Thema sein. Ursprünglich, als es noch alles in Planung war, schon bei der 42. Ausgabe drüber gesprochen. Aber das ist im Prinzip der letzte Schrei. Die neuen Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, die jetzt auch mit einem neuen Konzept starten, dass sie nicht ein riesiger Bus mit allen möglichen Systemen, wie Envisat das seinerzeit hatte, sondern kleine Satelliten, die eben spezialisiert sind. Und unter anderem werden sie jetzt auch diese LCT-Technologie haben. Sind jetzt schon Sentinels gestartet, die LCTs an Bord haben?
So ist das.
Okay, welche sind das? Bisher ist es ja nur 1, A, 1, B, und ich glaube, 2A ist gestartet. 3 haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, oben. Sind die alle damit ausgestattet, oder nur der Sentinel?
Also da schäme ich mich wieder um das Thema, wo man sich natürlich mit unserer eigenen Technologieentwicklung befasst. Und das ist natürlich ein programmatischer Ding.
Okay, lass uns das mal laufen.
Ich benutze das heute allgemeingültige Wort, ich google mal.
Also Sentinel 2 hat definitiv...
Sentinel 2 auf jeden Fall, ja. Gut, das sind die Operativen. Was wir jetzt beschäftigen, weil ich natürlich in der Technologieentwicklung bin, das ist ja entwickelt. Wo wir jetzt natürlich entwickeln sind Terminals, vor allem eben zum Boden. Also das sind jetzt Inter-Sightlight-Links, wie ich gesagt habe. Für die Kommunikation durch die Atmosphäre eignet sich dann vor allem die sogenannte Direct Detection. Eine andere Modulationsart, die nicht auf die Qualität der Welle unbedingt so angewiesen ist. Und was sich da etabliert hat, möchte ich sagen, sogenannte PPM, Pulse Position Modulation. Es hat verschiedene Gründe. Wenn Sie einen Zeitabschnitt unterteilen, sogenannte Slots, und Sie mit der genauen Uhr die Zeit verfolgen, dann je nachdem in welchem Zeitabschnitt ein Laserpuls gesendet wird, sprich empfangen wird, ist das entsprechend eine Zahl, sprich das Signal.
Also im Prinzip, was hier gemacht wird ist, es gibt hier in dem Sinne keine Amplitude, sondern man unterscheidet eigentlich im Prinzip nur Licht an, Licht aus, aber das kann man halt sehr schnell machen. Und man hat eine Zuordnung über die Zeit und in den einzelnen Slots ist dann halt die Frage, wo ist Licht, wo ist nicht Licht und damit macht man diese digitale Kodierung der Information.
Richtig, also danke, dass du das so schön geklebt hast. Licht an, Licht aus, ist natürlich daher kommt das, das ist sogenannte On-Off King, das ist quasi Licht an, Licht aus, 0, 1, 0, 1. Hier PPM geht es ein bisschen weiter, ist genau wie du gesagt hast, wann genau kommt das Licht. Das hat verschiedene Vorteile. Gut, einerseits wie gesagt, es ist einfach ein Puls, den man einfach detektiert, ohne einen Interferometer zu brauchen. Einerseits kommt die Technologie jetzt ins Spiel. Wenn ein Laser durch Average Power limitiert ist, das heisst, er hat eine maximale Leistung, die limitiert ist in seiner Mittelwert. Dann kann man in einem kurzen Puls die ganze Leistung, die ganze Energie loswerden. Das heisst, der Peak Power, der maximale Leistung ist einiges höher. Also wenn er ständig laufen würde, nur ein aus, ein aus, ein aus. Sondern man wartet und schießt alles auf einmal. Das heisst, in diesem Puls kommen viel mehr Photonen, viel mehr Signal an, als es sonst der Fall wäre. Das heisst, man kann von einer größeren Distanz kommunizieren. Die Ordnung dieser pp-Modulation unterteilt man jetzt das in 4, 16 oder 256 oder im Prinzip könnte man in einer unendlichen, wenn man eine unendliche Anzahl dieses Subslots, diese möglichen Zeitabschnitte hätte, könnte man das gesamte Wissen der Welt in einen Puls übertragen, je nachdem, wann er ankäme. Interessanterweise gesagt. Wo ist das Optimum? Das hängt jetzt genau nämlich davon ab, wie limitiert der Laser ist und wie gut man synchronisieren kann, wie gut die Kloks laufen und dementsprechend auch, je nach Distanz würde man das entsprechend anmachen. Aber das ist im Wesentlichen PPM, Puls Position Modulation. Vielleicht spring ich mal kurz zu einem anderen Thema, wenn du erlaubst. Wie gesagt, alles ist jetzt im Aufbruch. Wir haben seit über 30 Jahren das versucht, in SDEC und natürlich weltweit die NASA selbst natürlich irgendwie zu pushen. Und das hat so seine Anlaufzeit gebraucht. Wie du siehst, heute fliegen wir operationelle Satelliten. Es gibt einige Experimente in Europa auf LEOS und das ist fast jede Weltraumagentur, die Japaner fliegen. Die Franzosen sind noch am Überlegen. DLR hat schon geflogen, also auf LEOS. Die Schweizer Firma, ehemals Contra, ehemals Ruag und nun alles eine Schweiz, hat ein kleines Terminal entwickelt, Optel-Mü, auch bei Hilfe der ESA vom ARTES-Programm für optische Kommunikation, in Richtung Kommerzialisierung. Es ist alles im Aufbruch. Zusehends wird das Ganze wieder reifer. Die Technologie wird reifer auch für den Weltteil. Was natürlich noch aussteht, ist, dass das Ganze etwas billiger wird. Eines der Phänomene dazu ist, dass wir die Protokolle standardisieren. Also wenn du heute im Prinzip, ist die Übertragungstechnik im UK, wenn alles in der Schweiz standardisiert, du kaufst ein Radio und es funktioniert einfach. Das ist, es gibt nicht 50.000 verschiedene Arten der Modulation, sondern die Welt hat sich da geeinigt, gut natürlich von der Physik getrieben. Hier bei der Optik kann natürlich unendlich Möglichkeiten sich ausdenken, wie man die Protokolle macht.
Wie man das ja im Computerbereich auch immer wieder sieht, digitale Schnittstellen, alle paar Jahre kommt wieder ein neues Kabel, neuer Anschluss, neues Interface.
Du sagst es. Genau, du sagst es. Und um das zu, genauso VHS, Betamax, alles, nichts ist kompatibel. Wenn, es sprechen wir allerdings wirklich von Agenturen, also nicht von kommerziellen Einheiten dort, was da sein wird, bin ich gespannt.
Also, wir müssen nochmal kurz zu den Lesern gleich noch zurückkommen. Aber grundsätzlich haben wir ja gesehen, es gibt halt diese Entwicklung, man sieht, mit optischen Systemen können jetzt sehr viel effizientere Datenübertragungen vorgenommen werden. Man benötigt diese Datenübertragungen in diesem hohen Bandbreiten auf jeden Fall. Es gibt genug Missionen, wo es vollkommen klar ist, einerseits durch redefreudigere Sensorik, aber eben durch diese speziellen Anforderungen von zum Beispiel eben auch Audio- und Videoübertragungen. Die Technologie hat sich eigentlich über 20, 30 Jahre so weit gefestigt. Man weiß, es geht. Es bildet sich auch ein Standard heraus, zumindest schon mal was die reine Daten-Betragung betrifft. Und man geht jetzt auch den nächsten Schritt und sagt, okay, jetzt haben wir sozusagen die reine Physik an dieser Stelle auch schon mal ganz gut eingehegt. Jetzt wollen wir auch den nächsten Schritt gehen und das Ganze auch soweit standardisieren, dass alle künftigen Missionen auf derselben Übertragungsstandard bis auch ins letzte Detail machen, um einfach die Geräte noch günstiger herstellen zu können. Habe ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Ja, ich glaube auf großem Modus, ja. Genau, vielleicht ist es gut an dieser Stelle wirklich mal zusammenzufassen, dann können wir irgendwie noch ins Detail gehen. Genau wie du sagtest. Motivation. Also was ist optische Kommunikation? Statt Radio werden macht man halt einen Laser. Warum Laser? Weil das ist ein gebündelter Lichtstrahl. Mit einer Glühlampe kommst du nicht weit. Gut.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt genau? Und was sind jetzt eigentlich die Vorteile? Die haben wir ja schon zusammengefasst, aber was sind die Herausforderungen? Jetzt könnte man sagen, Laser funktioniert ja super. Warum haben wir das nicht schon immer gemacht? Das schrauben wir jetzt einfach auf alle Satelliten drauf und alles ist gut. Was macht es denn so knifflig und warum ist es noch nicht überall? So ein Laser muss ja auch extrem gut ausgerichtet werden. Wenn man jetzt nur einen kleinen Lichtradius allmacht. Funk kennt man ja, da hat man riesige Radioteleskope, die sich in so kompletten Bergtälern, Einlisten, alles Mögliche empfangen können und man macht vielleicht auch solche kompletten Arrays. Aber wenn so ein Laser wirklich nur auf einen sehr engen Punkt zeigt, dann muss man ja auch erstmal die richtige Stelle anvisiert bekommen. Das stelle ich mir schon relativ knifflig vor.
Du sagst es. Also wie gesagt nochmal zusammenfassend, wie du gesagt hast. Also gut Vorteile wie gesagt, hohe Bandbreiten, Störunanfälligkeit und vor allem Freiheit vom Spektrum. Das sind quasi ganz kurz zusammengefasst die Vorteile und da möchte man hingehen. Nachteile möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Es sind Herausforderungen. Herausforderungen sind nicht Nachteile. Das sind einfach das, wo man jetzt technisch entwickelt und so. Genau, woraus der Vorteil besteht, ist, dass der Strahl hoch gebündelt ist. Bedeutet aber auch, man muss genauer zielen. Sehr genau zielen. So ist es, sehr genau zielen. Dann durch die Atmosphäre, die Atmosphäre selber. Ganz einfach, die Schwierigkeiten, die Turbulenzen, die Zintillationen. Turbulenzen ist quasi das eine, dass das quasi die Wellenfront verzerrt ist. Das andere ist, je nach Größe des Teleskops kann es ja so sein, dass das Signal hin und wieder einfach verschwindet. Und nicht mal mit Wolken so rein durch die Atmosphäre. Das ist so eine Zintillation. Zintillation. Genau wie die Sterne.
Absorbiert?
Nein, weggelenkt. Du hast quasi das Licht in verschiedene Richtungen quasi abgelenkt. Also eine Wellenfront-Verzerrung führt dazu, dass die Wellenfront sich entsprechend anders ausbreitet. Und dann kriegst du halt, wie bei einem Laser-Show, wenn es auf eine Wand trifft, kriegst du Flecken. Das sind sogenannte Speckles. Die flicken überall und manchmal bist du im Augenblick mal kurz ohne Licht. Bei der hohen Datenraten, beim RF, wenn das passiert, dann verlierst du vielleicht ein paar Bits oder ein paar Kilobits und bei der optischen Kommunikation, die hohen Datenraten hast und eine Millisekunde auslässt, dann sind das schon einige. Unter Umständen schon Kilobits, Megabits weg. Deshalb braucht es andere Protokolle. Also überhaupt eine Kommunikation, das musste ich sehr naiv als Studium lernen. Damit die Daten sicher ankommen, muss man zusätzlich zu den Daten die Kodierung hinzufügen. Man kodiert die Daten und überträgt zusätzlich zu den Daten zusätzliche Information, die es erlaubt, Fehler auszuglätten. Und es kann so, dass wir sogenannten Coding gehen, also es kann durchaus sein, dass du übertragst doppelt so viel Daten, doppelt so viel Information aus die Daten selbst. Oder dreifach. Also ganz extrem. Das führt aber dazu, dass du schlussendlich viel mehr korrekte Daten kriegst, als wenn du es nicht machen würdest, dann fehlen dir die Hälfte von den Daten. Ich weiß, du kommst aus dem Bereich, das kannst du noch besser an zu Deutsch erklären, aber das ist dieser Coding-Verfahren.
Also erstmal sind ja richtige Daten, schlagen ja falsche Daten sowieso, 10 zu 1. Und darüber hinaus, klar, also man will sich ja auch sicher sein, dass das, was man empfängt, halt auch wirklich richtig ist. Von daher ist es ohnehin sinnvoll, mit entsprechenden Prüfungen zu arbeiten, um einfach die Daten überhaupt erstmal überprüfen zu können. Aber man kennt das ja auch so von Barcodes, nicht wahr? Wenn man so einen QR-Code hat, der heute irgendwo ist, dann kann man dem halt noch mehr Fehlertoleranz hinzufügen. Da wird der Barcode immer größer, hat immer mehr schwarz und weiße Punkte. Aber man kann halt auch mal irgendwo in der Mitte einfach die Hand draufhalten, das Ding fotografieren und immer noch alle Daten. Also da kann man sich das, glaube ich, ganz gut klar machen, dass sozusagen mehr, das hinzufügen von mehr fehlertoleranten Informationen dazu führt, dass man eben auch unter schlechten Bedingungen das Ganze dann optisch noch gut übertragen kann.
Richtig.
Also die Netto-Datenrate im Vergleich zur Bruttodatenrate.
Ja, und um die geht's. Also da die Maximierung, also man hat ein Overhead, das nimmt man im Kauf und das ist sehr wohl investiert. Und ohne das geht nirgends was. Und in der optischen Kommunikation werden andere Verfahren also noch andere Verfahren optimal als bei der RF heute üblich. Weil, wie gesagt, die Atmosphäre macht was und sogenannte Interleaving, also wenn man die Bits untereinander vermischt, sodass, wenn eine längere Zeit nichts kommt, wohl mehrere Bilder sozusagen affektiert sind. Aber die sind alle korrigierbar. Wenn man das nicht machen würde, dann verschwindet vielleicht ein Bild, aber das dann ganz. Also das sind so quasi die Vermischverfahren, Interleaving wahrscheinlich sehr zu einfach und deutsch ausgedrückt. Und solche Protokolle sind jetzt auch in Entwicklung, also nochmal die Herausforderungen, das genaue Ausrichten. Dazu braucht es sehr oft, wenn man von der Statistik und Kommunikation eine Bake. Das heißt, die Bake ist nichts als ein Laserstrahl, meistens nur rechte moduliert, damit man es von sonstigen nicht unterscheiden kann. Also die Stärke der Bake. Man muss ein stark genuges Signal weit genug zum Satelliten schicken, damit er einfach die Bake sieht und dann sein Terminal genauer ausrichtet.
Was genau ist eine Bake?
Eine Bake wie ein Laserstrahl, ein Beacon. Einfach ein Laserstrahl, der quasi die Position deiner Bodenstation signalisiert. Du schickst einfach einen starken Laser hoch, der zwar keine Daten trägt, aber hier bin ich. Du musst damit den Satelliten treffen. Damit ist er meistens auch etwas aufgeweitet. Der musst du auch genau treffen etc. Wenn der Satellit die Bake sieht, kann er genau an Bord dann sein Terminal, sein Laser auf deine Bodenstation ausrichten. Das ist z.B. Point Acquisition Tracking. Die Schwierigkeit besteht auch darin, dass man z.B. die Verfahren, sogenannten Handshake, wie sie heute bei Inter-Satellite Links, Sentinel, EDRS verwendet sind, wie die Reaktion, dass beide Terminal suchen einander abwechslungsweise. Die Spiralen. Der andere sieht ihn plötzlich ein Blip, richtet zurück, der Spirat, sogenannten Handshake. Das kannst du machen bei solchen Distanzen, wo die Lichtlaufzeit Millisekunden ist. Sobald wir aber von Deep Space sprechen, also Distanz zum Mars, da kann z.B. die Lichtlaufzeit 20 Minuten bis 300 Stunden dauern.
Kann man das nicht machen.
Das kann man nicht machen. Man muss was anderes überlegen. Und das sind die Schwierigkeiten. Das sind quasi jetzt die Herausforderungen.
Ich will da noch mal kurz einhaken, um zu verstehen, welchen Aufwand man jetzt eigentlich treiben muss, um ein Signal zu übertreiben. Nehmen wir mal als erstes Beispiel, was verhältnismäßig einfach ist. Ich habe jetzt ein Laser-Communication-Terminal auf dem Mond und ein anderes auf der Erde. Da ist ja jetzt nicht so viel Bewegung drin. Das ist ja relativ statisch. Mit welcher Energie muss ich überhaupt hier senden? Wie stark muss ein Laser sein, damit das überhaupt erst mal eine optische Kommunikation stattfinden kann durch die Atmosphäre? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Das kannst du nicht einfach mit einem Wort beantworten. Es hängt drauf an. Wie lange ist ein Stück String? Die beste Antwort ist folgendermassen. Es muss genug Energie gesandt werden, dass in deinem Teleskop, in deiner Aperture, je größer desto mehr sammelst du ein, je kleiner desto weniger sammelst du ein pro Zeitanheit, dein Detektor anspricht. Also ganz blöd gesagt, mindestens einen Foto musst du empfangen haben. Pro diesen PPM-Puls. Sprechen wir ruhig, PPM-Puls. Was ich kurz sagen wollte, ist, weltweit es zu standardisieren. Diese Protokolle, die kommen, die PPM, wir sind am entwickeln, weltweit im sogenannten CCSDS die Protokolle zu standardisieren, sodass jede Agentur fähig wäre, später miteinander zu kommunizieren. Das ist heute beim RF durchaus üblich. Sehr oft geben wir sogenannt Cross-Support, die NASA hat, sogenannte Deep Space Stations. Wir haben drei. Deep Space bedeutet, das sind dann 35 Meter Antennen, nicht eine 80 Meter Schüssel auf dem Dach. Übrigens, was dazu geführt hat, dass dieser Aufbruch überall stattfindet, jetzt auch im Deep Space, ich sage immer, es gibt nichts über eine erfolgreiche Demo, wo alle Menschen plötzlich wach werden. Und das ist in 2013 geschehen, also da war ich der Glückliche, ich war mit meinen Kollegen zusammen, wo wir da mitmachen konnten, mit einer NASA-Sonde, nämlich LADEE, Lunar Atmosphere and Dust Environment Explorer, das seine wissenschaftliche Mission um den Mond hatte. Und die NASA durfte darauf, als Demonstration, als ein Host-Payload, einen optischen Terminal fliegen. Und zwar derart gemünzt, dass es repräsentativ wäre für den Deep Space. Vom Mond kann es natürlich viel mehr Datenraten übertragen, als von LADEE möglich wäre und größere Powers etc. Aber hier war es wirklich eine Demo, ein kleines Terminal, und wir durften mit unserer Bodenstation das benutzen, um mitzumachen. Sogenannten Cross-Support. Das war sehr erfolgreich, das war auch nicht trivial. Wenn du möchtest, komme ich dazu aus. Wir hatten sehr wenige Möglichkeiten, die mussten klappen. Wenn die nicht klappen, dann hätten wir uns zehn Jahre zurückgeworfen in der ganzen, nicht unbedingt technologischen Entwicklung, aber das Bewusstsein der Menschen. Ganz konkret in diesem Beispiel, kann ich den sehr gerne nehmen, hat LADY an Bord, das ist das LCT, Lunar Communication Terminal, hat ein, glaube ich, 4 Watt Laser an Bord gehabt, wovon allerdings fast immer nur ein halber Watt gebraucht wurde. Einmal hat man es in einem 1 Watt Modus betrieben und auf der Erde hatten wir ein 1 Meter Teleskop. Das eigentliche Experiment von MIT Lincoln Labs hatte in White Sands ein Bodenterminal mit 4 40 Zentimeter Empfangsteleskopen, ein Array gehabt. Und die haben also mit dieser Konfiguration also ein halber Watt Laser Power am Mond, 4 mal 40 Zentimeter Aperturen, also Collecting Areas, mit sehr hoch empfindlichen Detektoren, das Superkonzept die Nano Wires ist eine Technologie, die Photon Counting, die man also Photonen zählt, 622 Megabit pro Sekunde erreicht.
Aber nur in eine Richtung?
Nur in eine Richtung.
Also es war nur ein Downlink sozusagen?
Nein, es gab auch ein Uplink, aber wie gesagt sehr asymmetrisch. Der war nicht so hoch, der war 20. Da war aber eine andere Konfiguration. In diesem Terminal waren dann vier, als möchte ich nicht lügen, 10 oder 15 Zentimeter Teleskope eingebaut um den Uplink. Einerseits das Bake, wie ich gesprochen habe, um sich finden zu lassen. Und da konnte man mit 4 ppm hochmoduliert 20 Megabit pro Sekunde senden. Das haben wir für unsere Bodenstation auch erreicht. Wir haben schön langsam beginnen wollen. Ich habe 10 Megabit pro Sekunde eingeschaltet und wir hatten nur für 6 Sekunden quasi wegen anderen Problemen, die wirklich Daten senden können. Das klingt so wenig, aber in diesen 6 Sekunden haben wir so viel Daten übertragen können. Das war keine bedeutende, es war wirklich nur ein Experiment, wie man mit der Radiokommunikation 17 Stunden gebracht hat. Also sehr asymmetrisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob du deine Frage beantwortest.
Naja, im Prinzip, also die Gegenstelle war jetzt hier auf einem Satelliten, halber Watt Laser. Für den Ablenk ist aber dann ja sozusagen noch ein zweiter Laser auf dem Boden dann auch noch erforderlich.
Natürlich, nur schon für die Backe. Das heißt, du nimmst dieselbe Backe und modulierst die entsprechend.
Der war genauso stark? Der war auch nur ein halber Watt oder war der stärker?
Der war sicherlich stärker und ich möchte dich jetzt nicht anlügen, müsste ich nachgucken. Weil wie gesagt, das war nicht unser Terminal.
Aber im Prinzip, wenn man jetzt eine symmetrische Verbindung herstellen wollen würde, müsste es eigentlich auch ausreichen, auf der Erde genauso stark zu sein oder muss man, weil man direkt unter der Atmosphäre ist, erstmal stärker rausschießen?
Also es gibt, man will stärker rausschießen, ganz einfach, weil du einen breiteren Strahl haben möchtest. Wenn du es als Backe benützt, geht es ja darum, dass du den Satelliten treffen musst. Das heißt, du musst genauso genau wissen, wo er sich befindet. Das sagen dir die Flight Dynamics Leute wohl schon. Aber du möchtest also, sag mal, bei Ladi hatten wir so eine 10-Bugensekunden- breite Strahl haben wollen, dass du diese Ungenauigkeit triffst, was sicherlich den Satelliten beleuchtest und jetzt mit genügend Leistung, das heißt, je breiter der Strahl ist, geht natürlich die Intensität runter, wenn du die Leistung nicht erhöhst.
Ist das ein fester Parameter dieses Lasers, wie breit der strahlt oder lässt sich das im Prinzip einstellen?
Das lässt sich einstellen, das lässt sich zoomen. Das war natürlich beim Terminal von Lincoln Labs damals, bei Ladi Experiment, die konnten zoomen. Wir nicht, wir mussten aber auch nicht. Das heißt, das lässt sich zoomen.
Aber nur auf der Erdseite, nicht auf der Satellitenseite.
Du könntest beides, aber auf der Satellitenseite möchtest du möglichst wenig Komplexität, Masse haben.
Also da war es nicht so, es wäre theoretisch machbar, aber wäre natürlich aufwendiger.
Richtig, aber ist nicht nötig.
Ich versuche nur ein bisschen einzunähen, was braucht man jetzt tatsächlich? Meine erste Idee war ja sozusagen, jetzt mal eine Boden-Boden-Kommunikation von Mond zu Erde mir vorzustellen. Aber im Prinzip könnte man sagen, wenn man jetzt auf dem Mond ein äquivalentes Spiegelsystem hätte, wie jetzt auf der Erde, also ungefähr so ein Meter Durchmesser oder so ein kleines Face Array von kleineren Dingern, die sich auf eine entsprechende Fläche verteilen, zum Empfang. Das Ganze kombiniert mit so einem Laser, halbes Watt oder ein Watt. Und jeder, man muss sich sozusagen erstmal finden. Man muss ja überhaupt erstmal, wo bist du? Das heißt, man zoomt diesen Strahl etwas weiter auf, sendet quasi ein erstes Signal hin, aber damit hat man ja sozusagen noch gar keine Antwort. Also woher weiß man, dass man dann gefunden wurde? Also das ist sozusagen die Gegenstelle, die dann erstmal das Licht empfängt und weißt, okay, ich werde jetzt angeleuchtet, da ist etwas. Und dann weiß ich, wo ich hinziehen muss.
So ist es. Du weißt, dass du erfolgreich bist, wenn du angeleuchtet wirst. Nochmal ganz einfach erklärt, ich komme zu den Wattzahlen zurück, ich habe dir konkrete Werte. Du leuchtest den Satelliten aus. Wir wollten eigentlich dreimal 40 Watt senden, das kam aber nicht dazu. Technische Schwierigkeiten, wir haben dann schlussendlich praktisch nur 20 Watt erreicht meistens. Gut, das hat genügt, aber nicht so, dass wir nonstop kommunizieren konnten. Das Bage hat das genügt. Der Satellit sieht dich, weiß, woher er mit dem Laser schießen soll und sobald sein Signal bei dir ankommt, siehst du es.
Aber wie sieht man denn, woher der Laser kommt? Ich meine, man merkt ja erstmal nur, dass da kommen Photonen an, da kommen Bits an.
Du hast eine Kamera. Ich meine, genau wie du die Sterne beobachtest und siehst, wo die sind mit einer entsprechenden Kamera, entsprechender guter Optik, siehst du plötzlich, wo er ein Laserstrahl ist. Also das leuchtet dann plötzlich ganz hell.
Das ist aber nicht das, womit man eigentlich den Laser empfängt, sondern das ist nochmal ein separates Element.
Und da kommt jetzt wieder auf die Top-Technologie drauf an. Im Prinzip, also funktional ist das was Seperates. Funktional hast du eine 2D-Kamera. Das kann allerdings technisch, und da bin ich jetzt persönlich daran, was du entwickelst, was vielleicht dasselbe sein kann, anders, kann das getaktet, anders operiert, aber ist egal. Funktionen sind zwei verschiedene. Pointing, Acquisition und Tracking. Also eine separate Kamera. Du siehst, wo der Satellit ist, plötzlich weil er so hell aufleuchtet in deinem wellenigen Bereich. Ah, er hat mich gefunden. Und dann muss ich sagen, bewege ich das Teleskop oder einen kleinen Spiegel. Ich schaue zu, dass ich meinen Satelliten jetzt genau in die Mitte kriege.
Also wer hat denn angefangen mit dieser LLCD, bei diesem Demo-Experiment? Der hat der Satellit quasi den Strahlen?
Nein, der Boden.
Das heißt, man wusste, das Ding ist etwa an der und der Stelle. Man muss es ja erstmal eingrenzen. Man kann es jetzt nicht irgendwo hin strahlen.
Also gut, ganz ehrlich gesagt, der Satellit hat insofern angefangen, dass der Satellit mal zu sich einschalten muss. Und doch sein Empfangsteleskop zur Erde richten. Er muss ja deine Backe zuerst mal sehen. Wenn er dich zu den Sternen zündet, dann sieht er gar nie was. Also es muss beides quasi ausgerichtet sein. Beide wissen, wo sie ungefähr ja sind.
Also wirkt das Ganze erstmal mit Sternenbeobachtung an, damit man überhaupt weiß, wo bin ich eigentlich.
Ja gut, das ist ganz allgemein das Problem der Satellitennavigation selber. Das ist völlig unabhängig von irgendwelcher Kommunikation.
Also man verortet sich erstmal in Schritten nachzudenken. Also das Lied vergegenwärtigt sich in seiner Position. Das ist die Sternenkamera, die man in allen Missionen oder nahezu allen Missionen findet, insbesondere bei Deep Space Missionen. So dann weiß man überhaupt erstmal, okay, also die Sterne, die und die und die Konstellation, das kriege ich alles zusammengerechnet. Ich weiß, wo ich bin, weil nur an dieser Stelle...
Nicht wo du bist, aber wie du stehst.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin, aber ich weiß, wie ich ausgerichtet bin. So und dann kann man das quasi in Bezug... Wie weiß man, wo man dann ist? Also dann...
Das weiß der Boden. Nämlich genau aus dieser Methode, die ich erzählt habe, wo die Flight Dynamics Leute, quasi die Himmelsmechanik, deren Bewegungen... Du siehst von deinen normalen RF-Radio- Stationen, wo du dich befindest, ganz einfach mit der Ausrichtung. Also du siehst die viel breitere Strahlen, du triangulierst, also die wissen, wo du bist. Die wissen deine momentane Geschwindigkeit vom Doppler und deine Bewegung.
Das heißt, das kann man nur über die RF- Kommunikation sozusagen herausfinden, wo man sich genau befindet.
Gut, hoffe ich in der Zukunft dann auch über die optische, aber ja, genau.
Um das jetzt überhaupt erst mal hinzubekommen. Also, erster Schritt, wie bin ich ausgerichtet? Dann Radiotelekommunikation sagt mir, wo bin ich genau?
Richtig. Und heute zunehmend in Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten auch mit GPS. Die haben genau so wie wir hier um den Autos ein GPS-Empfänger an Bord. Also da weiß der Satellit auch, wo er so ist.
Okay, weil er kann ja die sehr gut sehen und kriegt dann auch die Zeitsignale etc. und kann sich das irgendwie... Okay, also der Satellit findet sich erst mal selber, dann weiß er eben auch, wohin muss ich mich ausrichten, um das optische Signal zu bekommen. Die Bodenstation fängt dann an zu leuchten. Das ist quasi so ein Leuchtfeuer, was dann irgendwie erst mal sagt so, hallo, du müsstest doch in etwa in diesem Bereich sein, so wurde es uns gesagt, mach doch mal Piep, wenn du das Licht siehst. Das Licht trifft auf, man sieht es, man sieht es erst mal, also man empfängt es, kann schon Daten empfangen und man kann im Prinzip in der Kamera auch genau sehen, ah okay, da kommt jetzt die Quelle genau her.
Richtig, vergift die Daten einfach, sei es die Quelle.
Na gut, man sieht Licht, aber da wird ja schon irgendwas inkodiert sein, was man sagt.
Muss nicht sein, aus technischen Gründen kann es, muss nicht sein.
Okay, also man geht einfach mal davon aus, wenn da Licht auftritt, dann ist das schon das, was ich erwartet habe. Na ja, weißt du, in 10, 20 Jahren kommt da vielleicht so viele Laserstrahlen von unten, dass man die dann schon auch unterscheiden.
Richtig, rein zur Unterscheidung muss man was machen.
Genau, kann ja sein, dass da irgend einer mit dem Laserpointer auch noch dann eben steht.
Die haben Gott sei Dank noch dort keine Chance. Da bin ich gut was Pilot, da bin ich, da ist was anderes.
Ja, aber die sind auch teilweise aus China so überdimensionierter. Da muss man sich glaube ich schon mal Gedanken machen.
Ja, sind nicht die Laserpointer, die leuchten, sind Menschen, die einfach, tut mir leid, ich muss es an dieser Stelle sagen, da habe ich negative Toleranz. Also ich selber als Privatflieger, ich bin als Passagier gesessen in einer Maschine, wo ich zurück von Paris nach Frankfurt kam und ich habe einen blühen Laserstrahl gesehen. Da habe ich keine Toleranz. Da werden Menschenleben gefährdet. Und dann habe ich mit den Piloten gesprochen. Ja, da sehen wir fast jedes Mal in Paris sowieso.
Das ist einfach irgendwelche Läder.
Das ist so ungefähr wie Leute, die einfach Steine auf die Autobahn werden, die von Deutschen schon gestorben sind. Wie gesagt, da habe ich sogar als Christ nur Toleranz. Gut, also nein, so einfach ist das nicht. Um nicht zu sagen, 120 Watt war es quasi bei unserem Beispiel damals drei kleine Aperturen. Ich komme noch zu einem kleinen Problemchen gerne dazu. Um dir eine größere Notung zu geben, wenn man zum Jupiter oder zum Mars wirklich mal was Sinnvolles in Sachen Backe. Irgendwo hört diese Methode auf. Und die hört wahrscheinlich dort auf. Bei Jupiter ist es unter Umständen wirklich zu. Du kriegst nicht einen starken Umgang. Wir sprechen dann von einigen Kilowatt. Also ich spreche von 8 x 1,1 Watt Laser, die du 8 Strahlen hochschießt. Also das sind so die Größenordnung. Bei den Amerikanern möchte ich wirklich nicht lügen. Das war wahrscheinlich auch ein paar 10 Watt. Ich bin auch mal 4 x 10. Ich muss es mal gucken.
Und du musst es mal zuversetzen für Leute, die so Laserdimensionen nicht im Kopf haben. Das ist ein verdammt fettes Teil.
Oh ja.
Bei dieser Kommunikation finde ich das interessant. Aber dieser Aspekt Sicherheit, wenn es auch heute noch nicht so ein Thema ist, wird es sicherlich in zunehmendem Maße ein Thema sein. Oh, da komme ich dazu. Dann habe ich diese erste Kommunikation aufgenommen. Jetzt sehen sich beide. Beide wissen, wo man ist. Und jeder kann seinen eigenen Laser in die andere Richtung schicken. Und im Prinzip mit dieser PPM Modulation beliebig viele Daten rein werfen, wie eben da sind. Und in dieser Demo wurde eben demonstriert, okay, mit dem fetten Laser von unten kommen 600, Entschuldigung, mit der großen Optik unten konnten 600 Megabit empfangen werden. Und mit der kleinen Optik im Satelliten kamen bis zu 20 Megabit oben an.
Gut, das ist nicht die Optik, die es limitiert hatte unbedingt. Man könnte natürlich auch beliebig viel von unten hochschießen. Das Experiment war so, wie gesagt, auch nicht nötig. Es war ein Demo-Experiment, wobei aber Gott sei Dank das Terminal die Möglichkeit hatte, die wissenschaftlichen Daten sonst immer über RF, also die Mission durfte nicht gefährdet werden. Das heißt, es durfte nicht abhängig sein von der Optik. Die war aber da, die war sehr erfolgreich und ziemlich bald haben die Wissenschaftler dann gerne über ein paar Minuten die Daten über Optik runtergekriegt und sofort gehabt, anstatt einen Tag zu warten, bis alles runterbröselt bei RF. Also, wie gesagt, es ist nicht unbedingt immer die Optik, die das bottleneck ist. Irgendwann wird es dann die Elektronik sein. Wenn man wirklich von 100 und von Gigabit spricht, dann müssen natürlich die Busse, also die Leitungen, die Elektronik und alles auch natürlich dafür ausgerichtet sein. Gut, hier war es eine Demo. Es wurde so designt und entsprechend hat es so gebaut und in diesen Rahmen betrieben.
Wollen wir diesen Sicherheitsaspekt nochmal kurz ansprechen?
Okay, du sprichst das dritte, also Schwierigkeit ist, eine Herausforderung, mit der man sich außerhalb setzen muss und mit der ich mich jetzt auch besonders auseinandersetze. Ganz einfach, weil ich auch in Laser-Ranging Richtung gehe. Für die ESA, also hoffentlich können wir...
Laser-Ranging?
Eine verwandte Technologie natürlich ist Laser-Distanzbestimmung sozusagen, Laser-Ranging. Die ist bei den Geodäten schon langtägliches Brot. Du benützt den Laser, wo du den Satelliten anleuchtest, nicht zur Kommunikation, sondern sein rückleffraktiertes Licht zum genauen Distanzbestimmung, durch Laufzeitbestimmung. Und das wird auch zum Mond gemacht, seit der Apollo-Mission natürlich, das sind genaue Distanzbestimmungen, das heißt natürlich Laser-Ranging. Das wird bei der geodätischen Community benützt, um zum Beispiel die Erdkrustenbewegung und Rotation alles zu vermessen anhand von Satelliten, deren Bahnen man sehr gut kennt. Man kann es natürlich auch umgekehrt machen, in unserem Fall von der ESA, wir sind ja keine Geodäten, wir haben das Mandat, die Satellitposition genau zu bestimmen. Mithin zum vielleicht, und man ist daran, wir haben eine Aktivität gehabt, ein Freund von mir hat sie geleitet, ziemlich erfolgreich, wo bewiesen, wo man die Fähigkeit gezeigt hat, wie man einen Weltraum Schrott beleuchtet. Also ohne Retro-Reflektoren. Sogenannte Cooperative Targets sind solche Satelliten, welche seinen Retro-Reflektor haben, so wie ein Verkehrsschild anleuchtet, leuchtet es ziemlich genau zurück. Also kleinen Prismchen.
Das macht der Schrott natürlich nicht.
Das macht der Schrott nicht. Das heißt, du hast eine diffuse Reflektion. Und dennoch ging das. Und das ist dann unsere Aufgabe, deren Position, Bahn genauer zu bestimmen, um eben Kollisionen zu vermeiden. Die Geodaten machen das umgekehrt, damit Eichsatelliten die Ort überfliegen. Und das Problem bei der Kommunikation und bei Laser-Engine ist nämlich beides. Es ist nicht sogenannt i-Safe. Du hast natürlich mit Laser-Safety zu tun. Du kannst einen bestimmten Laser, wenn du ihn weit genug ausweist, so die Intensität so weit runterfahren, dieselbe Leistung verteilst über eine größere Aperture, dass wenn du reinguckst, ist es für dich ungefährlich. Was heißt gefährlich? Ungefährlich. Es gibt von entsprechenden Gremien ausgearbeitete medizinische Grenzen, die werden benannt Maximum Permissible Exposure, die maximal erlaubte, ja, ausgesetzt sein, maximal erlaubte Beleuchtungsstärke. Die ist Wellenlängen abhängig, aber da gibt's einen kleinen Sprung. Wellenlängen, sagen wir mal, bis mit so 1,1 oder so Mühe, also im Sichtbaren, die gehen ja durch das Auge durch und bestätigen die Netzhaut. Wir haben vorher kurz erwähnt Laser gegenüber Leuchtbirne. Laser zeignet sich ja darauf aus, dass alle, ein Licht besteht aus einer Welle, die bestehen aus allen Quantenteilchen, die für sich selbst eine Welle darstellen, sogenannte Photonen. Wenn die kohärent, das heißt alle im selben Takt schwingen, ist das eine sehr kohärente Lichtquelle, deren Wellenfront perfekt ist. Die kann man auch perfekt abbilden, sehr scharf abbilden. Die kann man auch entsprechend gut bündeln, weil sie eben kohärent ist. Und das macht ein Laser aus. Das ist die Laserquelle. Nichts anderes. Nichts anderes als das. Eine Glühbirne, da schwingen die Photonen, wie sie wollen, die kannst du wohl bündeln in einem Diaprojektor, aber niemals so scharf. Deshalb ist z.B. in einem Lasergucken, wo das Auge das sehr scharf abbildet, brennst du ein Loch quasi. Blöd gesagt brennst du dich an Netzhaut, an Wetter ein. Jenseits von 1,1 µ, also z.B. zweite Werneninger, die wir betrachten, für Kommunikation. Die eine ist Neodymium- technologiebedingt. Das sind die Laser, die an Industriemetall verarbeiten, sind die 1 µ. 1,5 µ ist das, was du gesprochen hast, terrestrisch, schon lange da ist. Dann bist du in einem Bereich, wo die Linse undurchsichtig ist. Dann absorbiert die und hitzt sich auf. Die Schwelle, bei der es die MPE-Schwelle, von der ich gerade gesprochen habe, ist 20 mal höher bei Infraroten als beim sichtbaren. Das heißt, du kannst 20 Mal mehr Intensität haben, bevor es unerlaubt wird und gefährlich ist. Auf jeden Fall aber sind solche Laser, Deep Space Communications, Debak und Laser Tracking, weil du wirklich bündeln möchtest und sind nicht all safe. Das heißt, du musst einfach lokal dafür sorgen, dass keine Menschen reinlaufen. Du darfst den Boden nicht belichten, alles noch okay. Du darfst aber keine Flugzeuge belüchten. Und das ist das eine, wo man natürlich Lösungen hat, sei es ein lokaler Radar, sei es ein Beobachter, und eine Kamera, die immer mit dem Laserstrahl mitfährt und sobald irgendwas da rein zu fliegen droht, schadet der Laser ab. Also da gibt es Lösungen, das ist nicht das Problem. Wenn du die Kommunikation kurz unterbrichst, bis das Flugzeug vorbei ist, ist auch nicht so schlimm. Es gibt ein zweites interessantes Problem. Es ist natürlich so, dass die besten Orte, die sich für diese Kommunikation, Laser-Ranging, eignen, sind dieselben Orte, die natürlich die besten Astronomie- Observatorien sind. Gutes Wetter, hohe Berge etc. Und man möchte genau dort hin. Und jetzt wollen die Astronomen natürlich nicht, dass überall Laser hoch ist und deren Beobachtungen nicht stören, mit rückreflektiert. Und das Problem ist auch unterdessen gelöst. Das musste gelöst werden, aber es sind Schwierigkeiten, mit denen man wirklich zu tun hat, bevor man einfach überall ein Tracking-Station aufstellt. Die Astronomen brauchen für die adaptive Optik, wenn sie schwache Stellen beobachten oder nicht helle Lichtquellen, brauchen dennoch eine Quelle, auf die sich ihre adaptive Optik einschießen kann. Die brauchen eine Referenz, idealerweise eine Punktquelle. Die adaptive Optik arbeitet derart, damit diese Punktquelle immer Punktquelle bleibt. Die beobachtet, was es tut, und verzerrt die Spiegel in Echtzeit, um die Atmosphäre real zu korrigieren. Richtig. Englisch gesagt, it locks onto the target. Wenn dein Stern so schwach ist, kannst du nicht, wenn du zu wenig Photonen hast. Die sind kaum genug, um zu beobachten. Also werden die, das hast du bestimmt auch schon gehört, so genannte Laser Guide Stars. Man erzeugt fast künstliche Sterne in ungefähr 80 Kilometer Höhe. Nichts ist perfekt, aber gut besser als nichts. Und erzeugt durch einen orangefarbenen Laser, erzeugt man Fluoreszenz der Natriumatome, die sich dort tummeln, die selber zu leuchten beginnen. Das heißt, man fokussiert an den Strahlen diese Richtung und hat in einem ganz scharfen wellengingenden Bereich einen künstlichen Stern erzeugt, sogenannten Guide Star, ein Light-Stern. Diese Technologie ist da, die brauchen die Astronomen selber. Und dennoch müssen die anderen Astronomen nicht gestört werden von diesen Lasern. Das ist auch quasi eine De-Conflicting Software, wo jedes Instrument auf diesem Hügel weiß, wer wohin beobachtet. Und dann guckt man, dass man sich aus dem Weg geht. Also da gibt es auch Lösungen, da sind natürlich auch etwas. Die andere Schwierigkeit, kurz wo du gesagt hast, apropos ja, was braucht man? Ich habe gesagt, wir haben drei, fünf Zentimeter Abendungen. Ja, warum denn mehr? Warum nicht eine? Und warum achtmal ein Kilowatt? Ich habe die Atmosphäre ja erwähnt. Auf dem Downlink kommt der Laserstrahl ziemlich ungestört. Den ganzen schönen Weg vom Mond kommt völlig ungestört. Perfekte Welle, bis sie auf die Atmosphäre trifft. Und nur die letzten paar Kilometer werden gestört. Das heißt, perfekter Strahl und breitet sich aus bis kurz vor deiner Nase und dann wieder gestört. Die kannst du entweder so hinnehmen. Wenn du eine groß genug Apertur hast, dann kriegst du nie ein Null. Also ein Meterteleskop genügt schon, damit du nie total Signalverlust hast. Nur wenn du ein kleines hast, dann hast du mal. Adaptive Optik funktioniert dann, damit du es schön bundeln kannst. Jetzt möchtest du aber einen perfekten Strahl, jetzt möchtest du das hochschießen. Und die Atmosphäre stört schon ganz zu Beginn. Das heißt, in den nächsten paar Kilometer hast du eine verzerrte Wellenfront. Und jetzt breitet sich die ganz sehr lange große Distanz eine verzerrte Wellenfront. Und also viel, viel größeren Effekt erzielst du dann am Ort des Satelliten. Also da flickert dann schön ganz was. Und dort hast du dann wirklich manchmal Nullen. Und um das zu vermeiden, kann man sagen, du überlagerst inkohärent mehrere Laserstrahlen gleichzeitig auf dem selben Ziel. Alle flicken für sich und haben da oben große Flecken, aber die überlagern sich statistisch so, dass das quasi Ganze verschmießt. Und das heißt Aperture Diversity.
Okay, wie stark muss man sich das vorstellen? Ich hab jetzt gerade so ein bisschen das Bild von so einer Angel, die so ins Wasser getaucht ist. Und man schaut dann so ins Wasser rein und sieht so auf den letzten Metern, da knickt es dann irgendwie weg. Auch dieses Aquariums-Effekt.
Okay, das ist die Brechung.
Genau. Aber das ist nicht so extrem. Also ist es nicht so, dass die Atmosphäre jetzt den direkten Laufweg des Lasers schon unmittelbar beeinflussen würde?
Ja doch, zu Anfang noch so wenig. Aber die ist jetzt noch so wenig gestört, propagiert, breitet sich aus, jetzt aber über diese langen Distanzen.
Genau.
Ein gestört, genau.
Das heißt, ich sende hoch und das heißt, ich kann gar nicht genau steuern oder kann zumindest nicht davon ausgehen, dass das Ding genauso gerade die Atmosphäre verlässt.
Okay, jetzt sprichst du ein Teil dieser Dinge an, nämlich nur die Auslenkung. Tip-Till, das ist nur die eine Komponente. Genau wie du gesagt hast, das ist mit dem Angelschnur. Das kann man noch relativ mit einem Spiegel steuern. Was ich meine, ist ganz was anderes. Höhere Ordnungen. Das heißt, nicht jetzt nur die Richtung, sondern die Verzerrung der Wellenfront aus einem dünnen Strahl wird ein chaotischer Strahl, das sich chaotisch ausbreitet. Ich übertreibe, wenn ich sage chaotisch.
Also nicht mehr so gebündelt.
Genau, nicht mehr so gebündelt oder gebündelt in vielen kleinen Bündelchen, die herumdrehen. Shower curtain effect ist quasi der Ausdruck dafür. Also die Duschvorhang. Wenn deine Lady hinter dem Duschvorhang duscht und sie kommt nahe an den Duschvorhang, dann siehst du sie noch, sie sieht dich zwar überhaupt nicht von außen, wenn sie etwas weiter weggeht, die Person, dann wird es krieg die Pus, dann siehst du gar nichts. Und das ist quasi diese Propagation, wo die stattfindet. Also da sind quasi die Schwierigkeiten.
Und wenn man jetzt mit mehreren Lasern parallel arbeitet, dann minimiert man diesen Effekt?
Sie dürfen nicht kohärent sein. Sie dürfen, also gut, kohärent, ich hab's schon mal erwähnt, ich hab hoffentlich alle mal in der Schule das Experiment gehabt, wo ihr den Laserstrahl durch zwei Schlitze fahren lassen habt, weil die eben Phasen gekoppelt sind. Die Phasen wissen voneinander, so blöd gesagt. Und ich bin immer im Takt, wenn du die zwei kleine Schlitze wieder aufeinander treffen lässt, dann hast du ein schönes Gittermuster. Welchen Tal auf welchen Tal, welchen Berg auf welchen Berg, und so geht das. Das ist Kohärenz. Wenn du das mit zwei Birnen machst, gibt's das nicht. Und das ist genau das Phänomen.
Jetzt sendet man bewusst inkohärente Signale hoch, damit die sich eben nicht so direkt treffen, sondern sich quasi diffus mischen.
Ganz richtig.
Der eigentlichen Diffusität damit wieder was entgegensetzen.
Der eine Laserstrahl, jeder für sich, wird natürlich da ein bisschen zerwackelt. Aber die untereinander zerwackelten Interferen dann im Prinzip nicht mehr. Was man macht, man verschiebt die Wellenlänge etwas, damit die inkohärent wird. Und das versucht man so zu minimieren. Genau.
Jetzt haben wir glaube ich so ein bisschen zusammengekehrt, wie so derzeit die Demos so gelaufen sind, welche Technologie sich quasi jetzt unmittelbar gerade anbietet bzw. auch auf den aktuellen Missionen zum Einsatz kommt. Wohin entwickelt sich denn das jetzt? Welche Anwendungsfälle werden jetzt hier noch möglich sein? Und was sind so die nächsten technologischen Schritte, die LCT machen muss, um sich weiter zu etablieren?
Ja, wie gesagt, die Technologie wird dann sehr von den Anwendungsfällen abhängen. Ich habe gesagt, nur schon die Distanzen, andere Technologien, andere Märkte. Also ich habe gesagt, es ist kein Markt, das Telekom ist ein Markt. Es kristallisiert sich eindeutig so heraus, dass zum Beispiel diese Leo-Satelliten, da ist ein Markt, jeder möchte kleine Satelliten fliegen mit einfach Bilder und die Bilder verkaufen, alle möglichen Services natürlich auch militärisch, ganz klar. Warum ist das noch nicht da? Ich habe gesagt, damit du vernünftig einen ununterbrochenen Link kriegst, wegen des Wetters brauchst du mehrere Stationen auf der Erde verteilt, damit du quasi, wenn hier der Wolk ist, da drunter gehst. Das sind Investitionen.
Dass man einfach umschalten kann. Dass man sagen kann, okay, den kann ich jetzt nicht erreichen, nehme ich einfach einen anderen, weil es ja egal ist. Ich muss ja nur meinen Spiegel ein bisschen drehen, fertig ist die Laube.
Richtig. Und wie die Strategie aussieht, ist auch nicht trivial, da gehe ich auch nicht mal erst hin, aber ganz klar. Und ein niedrig fliegendes Satellit, also nimm mal zum Beispiel die ISS gut, die ist dann relativ tief, also insofern schneller. Die umrendet die Erde so unter 90 Minuten und fliegt über alle möglichen Erdpunkte. Und wenn du jetzt eine Infrastruktur hättest, und dahin läuft die Entwicklung jetzt kommerziell, es gibt Firmen, die jetzt sagen, Andenken an 30 Bodenterminals, in diesem Sinne aber nur 1-Meter-Teleskope, man kann fast sagen Amateur-Teleskope, die hat allerdings nichts Amateurhaftes an sich. Man spricht so, da sind wirklich vernünftig kleine Teleskope, da geht es eher um Hosting Agreements, die Länder, die es erlauben. Sobald das auf der Erde steht, ist plötzlich eine Infrastruktur da, die du heute mit dem RF hast, optisch nicht. Und die Investition muss jemand tätigen. Sobald das da ist, gibt es plötzlich Users, dann wird jemand doch aus einem kleinen Satelliten einen kleinen Terminal haben, weil Optik ist ja da, so kann ich auch benutzen. Die RF-Schüsseln sind auf der Welt verteilt. Die kann man mieten, man fliegt. Und diese Investition, wie gesagt, jede neue Investition, das ist das eigentliche Problem bei ESOC, also bei überhaupten Satelliten. Einen neuen Satelliten, den man vorschlägt, damit er erfolgreich hat, will man so vorschlagen, dass man zeigt, ja, mit den existierenden Mitteln wird es klappen. Und die existierenden Mittel sind halt die RF-Stationen. Und möchte man jetzt die an den Boden-Stationen weiterentwickeln, dann stößt man an das Problem. Ja, aber braucht es ja nicht. Der Satellit, der jetzt quasi gebaut wird, der kommt mit dem neuen aus. Das ist so eine Chicken-and-Egg-Situation. An das muss man mal rauskommen. Das ist ja eine neue Generation von Kommunikation. Da muss irgendjemand, die Entscheidungsträger sagen, jetzt investieren wir.
Aber es ist einfach mal absehbar, dass wir vielleicht in eine Situation kommen, in der es vergleichbar zu Systemen wie S-Trac, also dem ESA-Kommunikationsnetzwerk weltweit verteilt verschiedene Bodenstationen haben.
Ich glaube ja.
Die als Gegenpunkte fungieren können, sodass es ja dann auch immer interessanter wird. Also da kommt man dann raus aus dieser Hunei-Situation. Das ist immer interessanter, wird das machen. Ich denke mir ja so Mars-Missionen. Oder auch so eine Mission wie Rosetta. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei den Distanzen jetzt für Laser auch wirklich schon realisierbar wäre. Aber es war ja auch teilweise das Problem, einfach die Datenmengen in absehbarer Zeit überhaupt übertragen zu können. Dadurch kann man ja auch ganz andere wissenschaftliche Ausbeute aus bestimmten Missionen machen, weil man sagen kann, ja, wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr vorselektieren, wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr groß komprimieren und damit auch Energie verbrauchen. Wir können auch einfach mal mehr Sensoren reinmachen, alles irgendwie erfassen, wir schicken das einfach runter und dann lassen wir die High-End-Computer da wochenlang drüber brüten, aber wir müssen diese Auswahl eben nicht in diesem delikaten kleinen Gerät machen.
Das ist das andere, jetzt kriegst du viel mehr Daten. Ja, völlig wichtig. So sagen, du sprichst jetzt eine Deep Space Rosetta, Deep Space, Stationen, Boden, das beginnt absehbar zu sein. Mein Szenario war dieses Low Earth Orbit Commercial Kleines, das ist eindeutig absehbar. Da gibt es heute, ich weiß, es gibt Bridgeset zum Beispiel, es gibt also wirklich kommerzielle Anbieter, die es absolut im Businessplan haben. Und das ist Investition auch eine andere als zum Beispiel eine. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Größenordnung. Entschuldige, du hast damals mich gefragt, apropos Laser hochschicken. Wie ist das, wenn ich jetzt von Mars einen vernünftigen Terminal, wie gesagt, oben möchte man die Masse Power minimieren. Auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, du musst am Boden einen großen Teleskop haben. Ich spreche immer noch vom Teleskop, obwohl politisch korrekt hier immer von einer Optical Antenne gesprochen wird. Und da sind wir im 12-Meter-Bereich. Und das ist nicht trivial. Logisch gibt es. Also 12 Meter Teleskope sind, ein alter Hut kann man nicht sagen, aber Grand Técan ist zehn. Also operationell die ESO wird nächsten zu einem 33 Meter, 38 Meter Teleskop haben. Ja, nur sind zwei Dinge. Wir haben Studien und das ist das, was unter anderem ich leite und Kollegen. Wir und die NASA selbst ist daran, die Entwicklung anzustoßen. Wir haben auch Studien, wie gesagt, mit entsprechenden Firmen. Wie baut man sowas, was weder ein Nachtteleskop ist, noch ein Sonnenteleskop, sondern Tag und Nacht operieren muss, wo die Sonne aus einem beliebigen Winkel auf dich scheint. Das gibt es Verzerrungen. Also Day and Night Operations ist ein Novum. Das hat doch niemand gebaut. Teleskope, ja. Das zweite ist, es muss einiges billiger sein. Also 120 Millionen für einen 10 Meter Teleskop. Das ist natürlich für Astronomen wunderbar. Aber wenn du drei solche aufstellen möchtest, muss man konkurrenzfähig bleiben. Also das ist möglichst billig. Allerdings wollen wir auch nicht unbedingt astronomisch, wir haben ein anderes Pflichtenheft. Wir müssen quasi nur Photonen empfangen. Wir wollen sie nicht abbilden. Das war auch eine Lernkurve. Doch, wir müssen abbilden. Damit du das kleine Signal auch auf einen kleinen Detektor bringst, musst du eine gute Abbildungsfähigkeit haben. Genauso ein Teleskop, allerdings nur im Zentrum, nicht in einem weiten Feld. Und das gilt jetzt wirklich neu zu designen, oft möglichst billiger. Das haben wir dran am Anfang. Zukunft in diesem Deep Space Feld. Die NASA WIRD, das ist jetzt selektiert worden, WIRD, ein optisches Terminal Deep Space. Wie gesagt, eine logische Folge von diesem LADEE. Auf einem Saturitenfliegen, das zum astroiden Psyche fliegen wird. Sogenannte DSOCK, Deep Space Optical Communication Terminal. Ist das Terminal zum Entwicklung. Und die NASA hat jetzt eine Mission. Wir hatten damals die Mission AEM, Asteroid Impact Mission, studiert. Die wurde im Ministerial Council momentan nicht bewilligt. Die wäre jetzt einem Doppelastroiden geflogen. Im Moment studieren wir die Akkommodation. Also wir studieren anhand der Space Weather Mission, die vorgeschlagen wird im Lagrash Pump 5, L5. Also genau in einer AU, also 150 Millionen Kilometer Entfernung. Hinter der Erde auf der Säbenumlaufbahn, quasi 60 Grad weg von der Sonne. Vom Space Weather die Sonnebeobachtung, um quasi uns vorzuwarnen von Sonnenwind und dergleichen Redaktion. Diese Mission würde sich auch perfekt eignen, um ein optisches Terminal zu fliegen. Da sind wir genau daran. Es ist natürlich noch keine Mission. Es ist auch nicht approved. Wir haben noch kein Mandat, eine Bodenstation dazu zu bauen. Aber hierzu wäre eine 4-Meter-Bodenstation zum Beispiel sehr genügend. Ich persönlich bin ein Gläubiger einer Array-Solution. Statt dass man eine 12-Meter-Bodenantenne baut, die zwangsläufig segmentiert ist und man die einzelnen Segmente zueinander steuern muss. Unser Tod, anhand eines Astronomers, wäre Streulicht. Wir wollen relativ nahe an die Sonne gehen, sonst verliert man sehr viel Todzeit bei den Planeten, wenn sich der Mars vor oder hinter der Sonne bewegt. Wenn man weit weg abschalten muss, dann dauert das natürlich, verlieren wir Monate, Wochen. Streulicht der Sonne ist das, was uns Kopfweh macht, und deshalb ist das das größte Problem. Statt 12 Meter kannst du dir vorstellen, dass man 9 4-Meter-Teleskope aufbaut, ungefähr die selbe Area. Im Gegensatz zum VLA und zu den Astronomen ist das kein Phased Array. Die Schwierigkeit um alles, wir wollen ja nicht abbilden de facto, wir wollen nur Photonen zählen. Wir brauchen also nicht kein Co-Phasing. Wir brauchen aber wohl eine Synchronisation. Jetzt statt dass du beispielsweise klassisch, das kann ich so sagen, so ein Benchmark von Mars, 10 Photonen pro Puls, Puls kann in diesem Fall wahrscheinlich ein paar Nanosekunden breit sein, da gibt es 16 ppm, da kommt wieder ein nächstes Frame. Hast du jetzt natürlich auf neun einzelne Teleskope verteilt, aber vielleicht nur ein Photon pro Puls jeweils. Und die gilt es zu synchronisieren. Du kommst mal an Photonen hin und wieder, du musst auch wissen, wo quasi diese Frames und diese Bins begonnen haben. Also wirklich zeit synchronisieren. Es ist nicht trivial. Das ist ein anderes Feld, das man natürlich abklopfen muss. Aber ich glaube, dass das vielleicht die Lösung sein wird, ganz einfach, weil das die einzige skalierbare ist. Wenn du ein Viermeter Teleskop, und das kann man monolithisch machen, da hast du keine Probleme mit Segmentierung, einiges günstiger, das spricht man von, schwer zu sagen, 15, 20 Millionen, vielleicht das erste, dann soll es günstiger sein. Das ist unser Ziel. Da kannst du schon sehr viel machen, von Mond, Lagrange. Sobald du mehr investieren kannst, baut ein zweites hinzu, ein drittes, ein viertes. Wenn du ein Array hast, kannst du dir plötzlich auch verschiedene Missionen verteilen. Da kannst du zwei Missionen auf Lagrange 1, Lagrange 5 betreuen. Also das seh ich persönlich, das ist meine Vision. Das ist Igor, nicht dieser. Und ich glaub, das ist wirklich im Aufbruch, Studien laufen, NASA wird fliegen. Wir hoffen, dass wir auf L5 fliegen werden. Das ist ungefähr im selben Rahmen. 2023 startet in diesem Rahmen. Eine 4-Meter-Antenne hoffen wir, dazu bauen zu dürfen. Das ist mein persönliches Hobby hier auch. Andere Anwendungsfälle, die rell laufen, wo die ESA auch Experimente hatte. Am Boden zum Beispiel ist Quantum-Kommunikation, die Verteilung von Quantum-Schlüsseln. QQD, Quantum Key Distribution, das ist, wird auch kommerziell studiert. Dazu musst du Photonen, verschränkte Photonen, Dangle Photons nach Einstein, an zwei verschiedenen Stationen verteilen. Also, der dritte Bereich übrigens, Bandbreite sein, das eine, Spektrumfreiheit das andere, und das dritte ist eben diese Sicherheit, diese Übertragungssicherheit, Störfestigkeit, das eine und das andere ist quasi die Kryptographie. Ohne, dass du was irgendwie verschlüsselst, ist es schon schwierig, irgendwo in einen optischen Strahl reinzuhorchen. Also das ist schon mal schön. Wenn man allerdings eine absolute kripto, absolute, wirklich physikalisch, absolut unknackbare Verschlüsselung haben möchtest, du kommst ja vom Bereich Internet. Da musst du wirklich das quantummäßig machen. Da musst du das quantisch machen. Und dazu ist das große Wort Verteilung eines Schlüssels über große Distanzen. Also wenn wir zum einen Chinesen sind, da lieg ich jetzt sehr am Vorsch, am Vorpreschen auch mit Österreich zusammen. Dazu ist ein Szenario, das einzig wirklich gangbares Szenario. Wenn du zum Beispiel zwischen Amerika und Europa kommunizieren möchtest, absolut hundertprozentig sicher, musst du an beiden Orten einen Schlüssel verteilen, und zwar Photonen. Und das kannst du quasi nur aus dem Weltteil vernünftig machen. Das wurde auch gezeigt, das geht experimentell natürlich. Und das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Anwendungssache, wo jetzt natürlich wir vom Deep Space nichts damit zu tun haben. Dazu wurden Experimente zwischen den Inseln. Ein Standort übrigens, wo ESA schon eine optische Ground Station hat, ist Tenerife. Da sind schon astronomische Observatorien ansehend. Eine auf Tenerife, eine auf La Palma. Unter dem Schirmherrschaften Instituto Astrofisico de Canarias. Und da wurden zwischen La Palma und Tenerife schon Quantum Experimente oder Deep-Spec-Experimenten durchgeführt. Das sind nicht solche Dinge. Also so weit zu Anwendungen. Kommunikation, Kryptographie, Laser-Ranging.
Wow, ein weites Feld.
Oh ja.
Noch mal so ein kleines Detail nachgefragt, wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht, dass es die entsprechenden Teleskope gibt und natürlich dann auch ausgerüstete Missionen und die Kommunikation hergestellt werden kann. Von was für Bandbreiten kann man denn so träumen zwischen Mond und Erde oder Mars und Erde oder weiteren Zielen? Wie weit hätte man denn mit Technologie der Zukunft?
Vielleicht sogar greifbar. Vielleicht sogar greifbar. Wie gesagt, ist alles im Aufwand von, ja, wenn man von Operatoren spricht, halt Geld und von Power on Board. Ich nenne das immer so der heilige Gral. Der Holy Grail heute ist so 100 Megabit pro Sekunde aus einer Distanz von einer AU. Oder L5 zur Erde. Das Schöne an L5 und wirklich, das wäre eine super Demo, ist, dass die Sonne 60 Grad weg ist vom Saturiten. Und die Erde eben auch vom Saturiten gesehen 60 Grad weg ist von der Sonne. Also die Sonne stört nicht in beiden Richtungen. Mein Beispiel, da sehen wir momentan vor, die Studie, wie wir sehen, peilen wir eindeutig mindestens 10 Megabit pro Sekunde realistisch an, damit es attraktiv ist zur existierenden RF-Lösung, die 300 Kilobit pro Sekunde heute vorsieht. Ich hoffe, ich spreche da nicht aus der Schule. Aber angestebt ist so quasi wirklich ein, außer einer AU, 100 Megabit pro Sekunde und dann skaliert sich dann natürlich im Quadrat der Distanz.
Was für Missionen? Also L5 ist der Lagrange-Punkt, also einer, der hat mir vorhin schon angesprochen, einer dieser Punkte, wo sich die Gravitation der Erde und der Sonne ausgleichen und man dann sozusagen an einem konstanten Abstand hinter der Erde herfahren kann. In dem Fall bei L5, also sozusagen auf der Erdbahn, aber eben genau so weit weg wie die Sonne. Nur eben auf der Erdbahn.
Du hast ein dreiseitiges Dreieck für das Satellit.
Das würde sich anbieten für was für Beobachtungen?
Das ist die Sonnenbeobachtung übrigens. Aus einem Winkel von 60 Grad. Und zwar derart, dass wie die Sonne sich dreht, einmal um 28 Tage dreht sie sich ja selber. Und das ist dann zu der noch erdabgewandten Seite, wo man ein paar Tage später, eine Woche später dann, also du beobachtest Phänomene auf der Sonnenoberfläche, sprich coronal mass ejections, hohe Teilchen, die beschleunigt werden, die dann auf der Erde dann wirklich was auslösen. Es gibt Blackouts, es gibt Korrosion auf den Pipelines, also da sind ganz kommerzielle Interesse dran. Und natürlich auch so ein Space Weather, unsere Einbettung in das System.
Aber man sieht es sozusagen, bevor es für uns relevant wird.
Richtig. Du siehst es bevor dieser Teil der Sonne sich zur Erde dreht. Das ist das Spezielle daran.
Und dann könnte man halt sehr hochauflösende Datenströme permanent übertragen, was derzeit einfach so gar nicht vorstellbar ist.
Genau. Du hast Latency angesprochen, das ist nicht das andere. Latenz bedeutet die Zeit, von der du beobachtet hast, bis du die Daten im Sack hast. Das ist bei Optik heute nicht unbedingt gut, außer Inter-Sightlight links. Aber am Boden, wenn du warten musst, und überhaupt nicht bei der Optik warten musst, bis eine Station in Sicht ist, beeinflusst das die Latency, also diesen Delay. Damit diese Mission, diese Mission eindeutig, das ist wirklich ein Operationscharakter. Die muss ständig in einer RF-Station verbunden werden. Das no latency erlaubt. Also die Mission selber ist mit RF, das ist die Mission requirement. Die Optik käme jetzt als schöner Bonus-Zusatz dazu, nämlich die vielleicht hochauflösenden wissenschaftlichen Daten oder noch besseren Daten zur Vorwarnung, die man sonst nie runterbringt, jetzt dennoch runterbringt und wenn es ein bisschen länger dauert.
Ja, ich glaube, wir könnten jetzt hier noch stundenlang weiter fachsimpeln.
Und die Leute noch mehr verwirren.
Und die Leute noch mehr verwirren und mich auch. Aber das haben wir jetzt schon zwei Stunden lang gemacht, deswegen würde ich an diesem Punkt einfach mal einen Schlusspunkt setzen wollen und mich bedanken für die Ausführung zu LCT-Technologie und den ganzen Fragen, die damit verbunden sind. Sicherlich ein Thema, was aktuell bleibt bei kommenden Missionen.
Danke dir Tim. Danke von Herzen. Das Thema ist nahe an meinem Herzen. Wie gesagt, es wird noch viel Wasser fließen, aber es fließt. Es beginnt deutlich zu fließen.
Alles klar. Und ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit und sage Tschüss und bis bald.